I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Hi! Hi! Well, Jenna, I think we should just jump right in. We've got a lot to discuss. Why don't you tell them what we're talking about today? Search Committee Part 1, Season 7, Episode 25, written by Paul Lieberstein, directed by Jeff Blitz. Here's your summary. Desperate for a new boss, the employees of the Scranton Branch assemble
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。你好！嗨！嗨！好吧，珍娜，我觉得我们应该直接开始。我们有很多要讨论的。你为什么不告诉大家我们今天要谈论什么？《搜寻委员会》第一部分，第七季，第25集，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，杰夫·布里茨执导。这是你的摘要。斯克兰顿分公司的员工们急于寻找一位新老板，于是组建了
a search committee. But they are less than impressed with their applicants. The search committee is Jim, Gabe, and Toby. Mm-hmm. The pasty crew, I'd like to call them. That's a pretty good nickname. The pasty crew will be interviewing you. Dwight really wants to be considered for the job, despite the fact that he fired a gun in The Office. Mm-hmm. He is not a candidate, but he's going to make himself a candidate. Yes. All right, are you ready for Fast Fact Number 1? I've been waiting. You said you had something fun. Yeah, Fast Fact Number 1 is that this episode was originally 75 pages long. It's like a small phone book. I mean, movies are often 90 pages or 100 pages. Y'all, it was thick. It was.
一个搜寻委员会。但他们对申请者并不满意。搜寻委员会成员是吉姆、盖博和托比。嗯哼。我喜欢称他们为“苍白小分队”。这绰号真不错。苍白小分队将面试你。德怀特非常想争取这份工作，尽管他在办公室里开过枪。嗯哼。他不是候选人，但他要让自己成为候选人。是的。好了，准备好听第一个速记事实了吗？我一直在等。你说你有好玩的事。是的，第一个速记事实是这一集最初有75页长。就像一本小电话簿。我的意思是，电影通常是90页或100页。各位，它很厚。确实。
I reached out to Paul Lieberstein. Mm-hmm. He said he really enjoyed writing this episode. And I also found that the writers created a 23-page cliffhangers document. This was a document that included cliffhangers for every single character in the cast. Ooh. This is my favorite thing since finding the show Bible. I read all 23 pages. I wish I could just read them to you now. Every character had a cliffhanger for the whole season? Every character had like a cliffhanger, and then they said like what that cliffhanger would then become for season eight. Ooh. But then they didn't use all of them? They used like one or two? That's right. Okay. But they were so fun. Angela, your storyline about getting engaged to the
我联系了保罗·利伯斯坦。嗯哼。他说他非常喜欢写这一集。我还发现编剧们创建了一份23页的悬念文档。这是一份包含演员阵容中每个角色悬念的文档。噢。这是我自发现剧集圣经以来最喜欢的东西。我读完了所有23页。真希望我现在就能读给你听。每个角色在整个赛季都有悬念吗？每个角色都有一个悬念，然后他们会写下这个悬念在第八季会变成什么样。噢。但他们并没有全部使用？他们只用了其中一两个？没错。好吧。但它们太有趣了。安吉拉，你关于与
senator is in the cliffhanger document. And also the fact that people are trying to decide if they should tell you that he's gay, also in the document. Okay. All of that made it into the script, made it into the story. But the writing staff clearly loved the storyline because they dedicated seven pages to it. Come on. It was the most pitches of any character. The second most pitches were on a Ryan Kelly storyline that never came to fruition. What was their cliffhanger? Basically, every pitch was that Ryan finds out he has a child. Oh, no way. Or that Kelly is pregnant with Ryan's child. Oh my gosh. Yeah. In some cases, Ryan's child is like 13 years old. In some cases, Ryan's child is three. One of the pitches
参议员订婚的故事情节就在悬念文档里。还有人们试图决定是否应该告诉你他是同性恋的事实，也在文档里。好吧。所有这些都进入了剧本，进入了故事。但编剧团队显然很喜欢这个故事情节，因为他们为此贡献了七页篇幅。得了吧。这是所有角色中提案最多的。第二多的提案是关于瑞安·凯利的一个从未实现的故事情节。他们的悬念是什么？基本上，每个提案都是瑞安发现他有一个孩子。噢，不会吧。或者凯利怀上了瑞安的孩子。天哪。是的。在某些情况下，瑞安的孩子大约13岁。在某些情况下，瑞安的孩子是三岁。其中一个提案
I really liked was that Ryan and Pam get together for a play date with their two children. They're toddlers. That was sort of fun. There was also a pitch for Jim and Pam that made me laugh out loud, which was that they were going to find out that a disgraced person, like a person who does something that goes viral in a not great way, has the name Cece Halpert. Oh, no. And they have to decide if they're going to legally change her name. Because everyone's talking about whatever sh** show is Cece Halpert online. That's right. That's funny, right? Yeah, that is funny. It's really funny. Yeah. I mean, I feel like I know people who have famous people names. And I always wonder what's that like? Like,
我真的很喜欢，那就是瑞安和帕姆带着他们的两个孩子去玩耍。他们是蹒跚学步的孩子。那挺有趣的。还有一个关于吉姆和帕姆的提案让我大笑出声，那就是他们会发现一个声名狼藉的人，比如一个做了某种以不太好的方式走红的事情的人，名字叫西西·哈珀特。噢，不。他们必须决定是否要合法地更改她的名字。因为每个人都在网上谈论西西·哈珀特到底是什么烂摊子。没错。那很有趣，对吧？是的，那很有趣。真的很有趣。是的。我的意思是，我觉得我认识名字和名人一样的人。我总是想知道那是什么感觉？比如，
I know a regular guy named Steve Martin. Oh my gosh. What happens when he makes a reservation? He lives in California. Steve Martin, but not Steve Martin, the comedian. Yeah. Like Brad Pitt, but I live in Nebraska. I wonder if there's a Nebraska Brad Pitt. I don't know. But that's a funny idea. All right. Do you want fast fact number two? Yolls. Okay. The main plot of this episode is that Jim, Gabe, and Toby are interviewing applicants to be the new manager. And this is going to bring in a slew of famous cameos. We have, in this episode, Will Arnett, Warren Buffett, Ray Romano, Ricky Gervais, Catherine Tate, James Spader, and Jim Carrey. Jim Carrey is actually in part two. Yes. But you get it.
我认识一个叫史蒂夫·马丁的普通人。天哪。当他预订时会发生什么？他住在加利福尼亚。史蒂夫·马丁，但不是那个喜剧演员史蒂夫·马丁。是的。就像布拉德·皮特，但我住在内布拉斯加州。我想知道有没有内布拉斯加州的布拉德·皮特。我不知道。但这主意很有趣。好了。你想要第二个速记事实吗？各位。好吧。这一集的主要情节是吉姆、盖博和托比正在面试申请新经理的人。这将带来一大批著名的客串明星。在这一集中，我们有威尔·阿奈特、沃伦·巴菲特、雷·罗马诺、瑞奇·热维斯、凯瑟琳·塔特、詹姆斯·斯派德和吉姆·凯瑞。吉姆·凯瑞实际上在第二部分。是的。但你懂的。
Fingerlegs guy. Fingerlegs. That's right. Victoria Kay from Wisconsin said, was this episode sort of a trial run for which of the guest stars would be a good fit for the show in upcoming seasons? And Jake M from Delaware said when Paul Lieberstein was writing this episode, did he know who the guest stars would be and did he write parts based on their strengths or did they cast people after the script has been written? That's a good question. Yeah. I would like to know that. Well, I talked to Paul and he said, no, they wrote the script and then they started reaching out to people. Oh, because I swear the way they wrote Merv was Ray Romano. Like in my mind, if I had to cast anyone as Merv, it would be Ray Romano.
“腿腿”男。腿腿。没错。来自威斯康星州的维多利亚·凯说，这一集是否算是对哪些客座明星适合未来几季演出的试水？来自特拉华州的杰克·M说，当保罗·利伯斯坦写这一集时，他是否知道客座明星会是谁，他是根据他们的优势写角色，还是在剧本写好后才选角？这是个好问题。是的。我也想知道。嗯，我和保罗谈过，他说，不，他们写了剧本，然后才开始联系人。噢，因为我发誓他们写默夫的方式就是雷·罗马诺。就像在我脑海里，如果我必须选任何人演默夫，那一定是雷·罗马诺。
So I was wondering which came first. Paul also said that they had not made any decisions about who would be joining us as a potential manager for season eight. The cameo actors were not even necessarily being considered for roles, not even James Bader or Catherine Tate who actually ended up joining us. Paul also said the way we got most people was that they just called them up and said, hey, do you want to play this part? And everybody they called said yes. That's basically how we get guests on office ladies. We just text or call someone and say, do you guys want to come on our show? And then they say yes or no in some cases. Or no, I'm filming in, where was Keanu Reeves filming? Remember when we reached out? Oh, yeah. He was, he was like somewhere,
所以我很好奇哪个先出现。保罗还说，他们还没有决定谁将作为第八季的潜在经理加入我们。客串演员甚至不一定被考虑担任角色，甚至连詹姆斯·斯派德或凯瑟琳·塔特都没有，尽管他们最终加入了我们。保罗还说，我们获得大多数人的方式就是给他们打电话说，嘿，你想演这个角色吗？他们打电话的每个人都说了是。这基本上就是我们在《办公室女士》中邀请嘉宾的方式。我们只是发短信或打电话给某人说，你们想来我们的节目吗？然后他们说愿意，或者在某些情况下说不。或者不，我正在拍摄，基努·里维斯在哪里拍摄？记得我们联系的时候吗？噢，是的。他当时，他当时在某个地方，
like, like seriously, he was where he was like in Rome or somewhere. You know, one of our big guest stars was Will Arnett, who I have done two movies with. I did a movie called Brother Solomon with him. Yes. It's a very funny scene where we are on our very first date and he proposes marriage to me in a restaurant. And I have to awkwardly say no. But of course, people in the restaurant don't know it's our first day. Right. So they're rooting for him. So awkward. It's amazing. And then I also worked with him in Blades of Glory. He is a wonderful person. I reached out to him to ask him about getting his role on the office and he sent in audio clips. Oh my gosh, this means we get to hear his voice because this man could read the phone book to me. I love his voice. I don't
就像，就像说真的，他在罗马或者某个地方。你知道，我们的大牌客座明星之一是威尔·阿奈特，我和他拍过两部电影。我拍过一部叫《所罗门兄弟》的电影。是的。有一个非常有趣的场景，我们在第一次约会时，他在餐厅向我求婚。我不得不尴尬地拒绝。但当然，餐厅里的人不知道这是我们的第一次约会。对。所以他们支持他。太尴尬了。太棒了。然后我也在《荣誉之刃》中和他合作过。他是一个很棒的人。我联系他询问他获得《办公室》角色的事，他发来了音频片段。天哪，这意味着我们可以听到他的声音，因为这个男人可以给我读电话簿。我喜欢他的声音。我不
know him at all. But I love his voice. His voice is in my house all the time because of the Lego movie. Oh yes. And incidentally, Lego Masters was like our first big family show that helped us get through the beginning of the pandemic. You guys love that show. We love it. All right. Here is what Will had to say about coming on our show. I remember getting a call, I guess from my agent saying that Paul Lieberstein from the office, who is obviously the showrunner and one of the stars of the show wanted to talk to me about a role. I knew that they were looking for a new boss on the show, the character of the boss. So we had a conversation or two and he'd said, hey, we've got this idea and would you want to come and do it? And I also remember him saying basically to the
一点也不认识他。但我喜欢他的声音。因为《乐高大电影》，他的声音一直在我家里。噢，是的。顺便说一句，《乐高大师》是我们第一部帮助我们度过疫情初期的大型家庭节目。你们喜欢那个节目。我们喜欢它。好了。这是威尔关于来我们节目所说的话。我记得接到一个电话，我想是我的经纪人打来的，说《办公室》的保罗·利伯斯坦，他显然是剧集的运作人也是主演之一，想和我谈谈一个角色。我知道他们正在寻找新的老板，老板这个角色。所以我们谈了一两次，他说，嘿，我们有个主意，你想来做吗？我也记得他基本上说了
effect, something to the effect of if it works out, would you be interested in doing it kind of long term joining the cast? And I was a fan of the show. And of course I knew a bunch of people on the show and thought, yeah, it would be great. And so we talked a few times and it was kind of left like, well, just come and do this episode, just come and do this scene. And then let's see how it goes. And I was like, great. At that same time, I was also talking to NBC, the network about doing a pilot for the Lord Michaels was producing written by my friend Emily Spivey with Christina Applegate. And it was a great pilot. And I just remember that they were both kind of happening around the same time. So there was a question as to whether or not I could actually do the
意思，大概意思是如果成功了，你是否有兴趣长期做下去，加入演员阵容？我是这个节目的粉丝。当然，我认识节目里的一群人，觉得，是的，那会很棒。所以我们谈了几次，最后大概是，好吧，就来做这一集，就来做这个场景。然后看看进展如何。我说，太棒了。与此同时，我也在和NBC电视网谈论制作一个由洛恩·迈克尔斯制作、我的朋友艾米丽·斯派维编剧、克里斯蒂娜·艾伯盖特主演的试播集。那是一个很棒的试播集。我只记得它们几乎同时发生。所以问题在于我是否真的能做
office even if I wanted to kind of longer term, even though they hadn't actually said that they wanted me to do that. But I do remember them kind of both coming around the same time and talking about actually doing up all night on my way to shoot the office. So anyway, I was a little confused as to what it was going to be. So I remember all that because I remember he did end up doing that show with Christina Applegate. It's really funny. Yeah. And I remember being super bummed because, you know, he and John Krasinski are really close buddies. And I had worked with him before. And John and I were campaigning heavily for Will to join the office to be the new branch manager or
《办公室》，即使我想长期做下去，尽管他们实际上并没有说他们想让我那样做。但我确实记得它们几乎同时出现，谈论在去拍摄《办公室》的路上做《整夜难眠》。所以无论如何，我有点困惑它会是什么。所以我记得所有这些，因为我记得他最终确实做了那个和克里斯蒂娜·艾伯盖特合作的节目。真的很有趣。是的。我记得当时超级沮丧，因为，你知道，他和约翰·卡拉辛斯基是好哥们。我以前和他合作过。约翰和我强烈游说威尔加入《办公室》成为新的分公司经理或者
just come on our show. We just like him so much. He's such a good guy. And we wanted him to be on the show so badly. And then he ended up doing that other show. Well, at least he got to come play one day. He did. And I did ask him what was it like to be on the set and doing that scene. And here is what he said. You come onto a show, especially a show like The Office that was really good. And everybody was, you know, at the top of their game. And you just don't want to stand out and be terrible. And you want to make sure that you're not, you know, coming in at a different volume from everybody else. But I was really excited because I was doing a scene with John Krasinski,
只是来我们的节目。我们太喜欢他了。他是个好人。我们非常希望他能参加节目。然后他最终做了那个别的节目。好吧，至少他能来玩一天。他确实来了。我确实问过他，在片场拍摄那个场景是什么感觉。这是他说的。你来到一个节目，特别是一个像《办公室》这样真的很棒的节目。每个人都处于最佳状态。你只是不想脱颖而出表现糟糕。你想确保你没有以不同于其他人的音量进入。但我真的很兴奋，因为我在和约翰·卡拉辛斯基演对手戏，
who is and still is one of my good friends. And that was exciting and fun. And then with Paul Lieberstein and Zach Woods. And we didn't really talk too much about what it was going to be. It was just kind of, I had read the scene and then, you know, we just, they're like, all right, they're ready. Let's go. And we just started, we just shot it. And it was pretty quick. My memory was that it was kind of over before I knew it. And how long am I supposed to talk for? Is this, am I just like 30 minutes? I was born in Toronto. I'm a Taurus. Oh, I remember it felt like it was over before it started to. Well, if you guys love Will Arnett the way we do, go to the DVDs. There is an extended
他现在仍然是我最好的朋友之一。那很令人兴奋，很有趣。然后是保罗·利伯斯坦和扎克·伍兹。我们并没有谈论太多它会是什么。只是，我读了剧本，然后，你知道，他们说，好吧，准备好了。走吧。我们就开始了，我们就拍了。而且很快。我的记忆是它在我意识到之前就结束了。我应该说多久？这是，我只是说30分钟吗？我出生在多伦多。我是金牛座。噢，我记得它感觉在开始之前就结束了。好吧，如果你们像我们一样喜欢威尔·阿奈特，去看DVD。这一集有一个加长的
producer's cut for this episode. And his scene has a lot more fun stuff. His character has a very funny story about being in the Navy. So if you like Will Arnett, go to the DVD extras. All right. Fast fact number three, we've talked about all the people from outside of Dunder Mifflin who are applying for this job, but there are three internal applicants. They are Daryl Philbin, Andy Bernard and Dwight Schrute. And after this episode aired, NBC.com posted their resumes online and you found them. Yes, office telly.com still has them. And I thought I'd read a little bit from each of their resumes. Let's start with Daryl. This is sort of alluded to in the episode. You know, Joe is going to say, why is your resume so long? Aren't you the same Daryl
制片人剪辑版。他的场景里有很多更有趣的东西。他的角色有一个关于在海军服役的非常有趣的故事。所以如果你喜欢威尔·阿奈特，去看DVD花絮。好了，第三个速记事实，我们谈论了所有来自邓德·米夫林外部申请这份工作的人，但有三名内部申请者。他们是达里尔·菲尔宾、安迪·伯纳德和德怀特·舒鲁特。这一集播出后，NBC.com在网上发布了他们的简历，你找到了它们。是的，officetally.com上还有。我想读一下他们简历中的一小部分。让我们从达里尔开始。这在这一集中有所暗示。你知道，乔会说，为什么你的简历这么长？你不是那个只在同一家公司做过两份工作的达里尔
Philbin that has only had two jobs at the same company? His resume is four pages long. Yes. Well, his resume does confirm that Daryl has only ever worked at Dunder Mifflin and it lists his starting date as June 1999. Under work experience, he has a line that says, quote, upheld the highest standard of safety amid the warehouse. The D'Angelo Vickers incident was the first happening of coma and will not result ever again. I can almost promise you that end quote. All right, on Andy's resume, something I found very charming is that the font for Cornell University is larger than any other font on the entire page, including the one for his name that tracks. It is also in bold and all caps. It looks like Andy worked, quote, brief, stressful, yet invaluable. Invaluable?
菲尔宾吗？他的简历有四页长。是的。好吧，他的简历确实证实了达里尔只在邓德·米夫林工作过，上面列出的开始日期是1999年6月。在工作经验下，他有一行字说，“引用，在仓库中保持了最高的安全标准。迪安杰洛·维克斯事件是第一次昏迷事件，绝不会再发生。我几乎可以向你保证，引用。”好了，在安迪的简历上，我发现有一点非常迷人，那就是康奈尔大学的字体比页面上任何其他字体都大，包括他名字的字体，这很符合他。它也是粗体和全大写。看起来安迪工作过，“简短、压力大但无价。无价？”
Invaluable. Okay. Stintz at AIG, Bear Stearns, Enron, and Lehman Brothers between 1996 and 1998. And then in 1999, he started working at Dunder Mifflin Stamford. And under his special skills, he of course lists Frolf and Banjo. I'm surprised he hasn't mentioned his summer studying to be a fromage. I know, the fromager. Yeah, fromager. Finally, Dwight Kurt Shrut, the third. Did we know he was of the third? I feel like somewhere he said he was Dwight K. Shrut, the third. I feel like that. Maybe. I have no memory of it. Okay. But it is listed on his resume. Okay. He lists his titles as Assistant Regional Manager, Manager Slash Sales Representative, Beat Farmer Slash Volunteer Sheriff Deputy,
“无价。好吧。在AIG、贝尔斯登、安然和雷曼兄弟工作过，时间在1996年到1998年之间。然后在1999年，他开始在邓德·米夫林斯坦福分公司工作。在特殊技能下，他当然列出了高尔夫球和班卓琴。我很惊讶他没有提到他学习成为奶酪师的那个夏天。我知道，奶酪师。是的，奶酪师。最后，德怀特·库尔特·舒鲁特三世。我们知道他是三世吗？我觉得他在某个地方说过他是德怀特·K·舒鲁特三世。我觉得是这样。也许吧。我一点记忆都没有。好吧。但它列在他的简历上。好吧。他列出的头衔是助理区域经理、经理/销售代表、甜菜农/志愿警长副手，
and Respected Capitalist. According to his resume, he has only ever been employed at Dunder Mifflin and he started in 1995. That's his only job? Yeah. I'm surprised by that. Me too. By the way, his special skills are listed before his professional experience. And here are his special skills. Wait, they're at the top? They are first on the resume. That is beautiful. Right? That is how I would love every resume to start. That is so good. It actually would be kind of nice. Yeah. You really are going to get a sense of the person first and then you're going to learn their job experience. Okay, go. All right. He is trained in the art of surveillance, possesses a purple belt in Goju Ryu, master of one-upmanship, expert in beat-related
和受人尊敬的资本家。根据他的简历，他只在邓德·米夫林工作过，他从1995年开始。那是他唯一的工作？是的。我很惊讶。我也是。顺便说一句，他的特殊技能列在专业经验之前。这是他的特殊技能。等等，它们在最上面？它们是简历上的第一项。那太美了。对吧？这就是我希望每份简历开始的方式。那太好了。实际上那会很不错。是的。你真的会先了解这个人，然后才会了解他的工作经验。好吧，开始。好了。他受过监视艺术训练，拥有刚柔流紫带，擅长胜人一筹，是甜菜相关
agrotourism, Senpai Maidojo, sci-fi pundit, table tennis champion, skilled at guitar and recorder, survivor of twin embolization syndrome. That's a nice callback. Right. And proficient in pre-industrial and religious German. Now, if that resume came across your desk and you read that, I would be dying to meet this person. Of course. It's like what Joe says in the second part. Like, I like a little bit of crazy. Yeah. See where this goes. All right. That's all I got. Those are my fast facts today. Well, they were fantastic. I think we should take a break because when we come back, I talked to Creed Bratton about this cold open and I can't wait to share with you. I can't wait to hear it. Well, we are back and Creed is going to zip into the parking lot
农业旅游专家，仙派迈道场，科幻评论家，乒乓球冠军，擅长吉他和竖笛，双栓塞综合征幸存者。那是个很好的呼应。对。精通前工业时代和宗教德语。现在，如果那份简历出现在你的办公桌上，你读了它，我会非常渴望见到这个人。当然。就像乔在第二部分说的那样。就像，我喜欢一点疯狂。是的。看看这会走向何方。好了。这就是我所有的了。这就是我今天的速记事实。嗯，它们太棒了。我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我和克里德·布拉顿谈了关于这个冷开场的事，我迫不及待想和你分享。我迫不及待想听听。好吧，我们回来了，克里德要开进停车场
in a really nice silver convertible Porsche. His license plate says new manager. You guys, I asked Creed about this scene and he told me he said, Ange, I had a Porsche back in my grassroot days. What? Yeah. And he said, so I told the producers I can drive this car because they were maybe going to get a stunt driver. He goes, no, no, no, I got this. I know how to drive this car. I'm familiar. And the way the scene was going to be done is that Creed would pull in to the parking lot, come to a screeching halt. Matt Stone, our camera operator, would be standing in the parking lot with a handheld camera. Okay. Right? Yeah. They told Creed where to stop, but they're like, Hey, Matt, we're going to make a little wall of sandbags around you. Smart. Because what if
开着一辆非常漂亮的银色敞篷保时捷。他的车牌写着“新经理”。各位，我问了克里德关于这个场景的事，他告诉我，他说，安吉，我在草根时期有一辆保时捷。什么？是的。他说，所以我告诉制片人我可以开这辆车，因为他们可能要找特技车手。他说，不，不，不，我能行。我知道怎么开这辆车。我很熟悉。这个场景的拍摄方式是克里德开进停车场，急刹车停下。我们的摄像师马特·斯通会站在停车场拿着手持摄像机。好吧。对吧？是的。他们告诉克里德在哪里停，但他们说，嘿，马特，我们要给你周围筑起一小堵沙袋墙。聪明。因为如果
Creed misses the mark? He could hit you. My gosh. And Matt was like, no, no, no, I trust Creed. I know he's got this. To be fair, are like a few sandbags going to really stop a speeding Porsche? I don't know. Okay. So Creed was like, Matt trusted me. I was like, I got this. He said, I pulled right up to him, hit the brakes. Matt didn't even flinch. He goes, look at the camera. It doesn't even budge. Wow. Yeah. Nerves of steel. They got the shot. And then he said, when he gets out, you know, Creed tosses the keys and says, keep it running, but there's no one there. Yes. He said, that was the third toss. Because the first two tosses, the camera couldn't find the keys. They had to kind of figure that out. Yeah. Where are you tossing those? Because he doesn't
克里德没停准呢？他可能会撞到你。天哪。马特说，不，不，不，我相信克里德。我知道他能行。公平地说，几个沙袋真的能挡住一辆超速的保时捷吗？我不知道。好吧。所以克里德说，马特信任我。我说，我能行。他说，我直接开到他面前，踩下刹车。马特连眼都没眨。他说，看摄像机。它甚至都没动。哇。是的。钢铁般的神经。他们拍到了镜头。然后他说，当他下车时，你知道，克里德扔出钥匙说，保持发动，但那里没人。是的。他说，那是第三次投掷。因为前两次投掷，摄像机没找到钥匙。他们不得不弄清楚。是的。你把它们扔到哪里去了？因为他没有
look, right? Right. But I love that Creed was like, I'll drive the Porsche. Yeah. Well, you know, I remember talking to Creed recently. And he said to me, Jenna, when you get to the part where I'm manager, I have some stories to tell. Oh, yeah. So I'm so glad you talked to him. We had such a fun conversation. I was like, Creed, you got to come in. And he said, well, and he calls me pumpkin, you know, he's like pumpkin, I'm going to New York, I'm recording my new album. You guys, he's 80. He's recording a new album. It's coming out soon, right? Yeah. He's working on it. I told him, I said, Creed, when your album comes out, you got to come on and talk to us about it. And he was like,
看，对吧？对。但我喜欢克里德说，我会开保时捷。是的。嗯，你知道，我记得最近和克里德谈过。他对我说，珍娜，当你讲到我当经理的那部分时，我有一些故事要讲。噢，是的。所以我很高兴你和他谈过。我们聊得很开心。我说，克里德，你得过来。他说，嗯，他叫我南瓜，你知道，他说南瓜，我要去纽约，我在录制我的新专辑。各位，他80岁了。他正在录制一张新专辑。快发行了，对吧？是的。他正在制作。我告诉他，我说，克里德，当你的专辑发行时，你得过来和我们谈谈。他说，
oh, I'll do that. And play us one of the songs in studio. Yeah. Well, here's a fun little tidbit from Randy Cordray. You know, you mentioned that his license plate says new manager. Yeah. New MGR. Yeah. They actually had to clear that. They had to make sure that there was not a Pennsylvania license plate with that exact lettering. And there wasn't. So we were able to use it. Wow. I know. I feel like if you're a diehard office fan and you love personalized plates, that's like a nice little nod. Hey, if you live in Pennsylvania, you should get that plate. I mean, maybe it's not still up for grabs, but it was at the time. Well, Creed is going to start off with the talking head. He's going to say,
噢，我会的。并在录音室为我们演奏其中一首歌。是的。好吧，这是兰迪·科德雷的一个有趣的小花絮。你知道，你提到他的车牌写着“新经理”。是的。新经理。是的。他们实际上必须清理它。他们必须确保没有带有确切字母的宾夕法尼亚州车牌。确实没有。所以我们能够使用它。哇。我知道。我觉得如果你是一个铁杆办公室粉丝，并且你喜欢个性化车牌，那就像是一个很好的小致敬。嘿，如果你住在宾夕法尼亚州，你应该弄那个车牌。我的意思是，也许它现在还没被抢走，但当时是。好吧，克里德要从谈话头开始。他要说，
do I love being manager? I love my kids. I love real estate. I love ceramics. I love my job. I love wrestling. While he's making this speech at 28 seconds, Michael's world's best boss mug is on his desk. Yes, because Michael gave it to Creed. Oh, I missed that. That's a good catch. I also love that we found out that he loves his kids. What? Excuse me? Yes. Nicole W. from Maryland was confused. Same as we are. I'm sorry, Nicole. We don't know. We don't know. I mean, Creed Show Bible must just be pages long. I know. At some point before our rewatch ends, I think you need to start off an episode just reading Creed Show Bible. Okay. I like this idea. Creed is dictating to Jordan a bunch of things,
我喜欢当经理吗？我爱我的孩子。我爱房地产。我爱陶瓷。我爱我的工作。我爱摔跤。当他在28秒时发表这段演讲时，迈克尔的“世界最佳老板”马克杯就在他的桌子上。是的，因为迈克尔把它给了克里德。噢，我错过了那个。那是个很好的发现。我也喜欢我们发现他爱他的孩子。什么？对不起？是的。来自马里兰州的妮可·W很困惑。和我们一样。对不起，妮可。我们不知道。我们不知道。我的意思是，克里德的剧集圣经一定有几页长。我知道。在我们重温结束前的某个时候，我觉得你需要开始一集，只读克里德的剧集圣经。好吧。我喜欢这个主意。克里德正在向乔丹口述一堆事情，
and he asked her to figure out what language this is, and then he speaks a bunch of gibberish. Yes. I went to the shooting draft to see what all was scripted. This was all scripted, except it did not describe the language. That was up to Creed. Oh, yes, what the gibberish would be. What it would sound like, what it would be. Creed told me he made that language up off the top of his head, but he had given himself a little backstory for his character that someday everyone would find out that Creed was an alien. Oh, okay. So he decided his made-up language should have an alien sound. So that's what he was going for. I get it. Mm-hmm. Do we need to hear his made-up language? I feel like we do. Find out what language this is.
他让她弄清楚这是什么语言，然后他说了一堆胡言乱语。是的。我去了拍摄草稿看看所有脚本写了什么。这些都是脚本写的，除了它没有描述语言。那取决于克里德。噢，是的，胡言乱语会是什么。听起来会是什么样，会是什么。克里德告诉我，他即兴编造了那种语言，但他为自己的角色设定了一个小背景故事，即有一天每个人都会发现克里德是个外星人。噢，好吧。所以他决定他编造的语言应该有一种外星人的声音。所以这就是他追求的目标。我明白了。嗯哼。我们需要听听他编造的语言吗？我觉得我们需要。找出这是什么语言。
I mean, I hear the alien. I hear it. Obviously, Creed said he loved running a conference room with only Kevin and Meredith in there, and he says, on this side of the room, Stanley Phyllis Jim Ted Elroy. On the other side of the room, Pam Meredith Phyllis Creed himself. I missed that. Oh my gosh. And then, you know, we have his bullpen meeting where he has his poster board that says Bobotty, and he's having everyone help him make this acronym. Kevin says B is for business. Creed gets very excited, and Creed in real life wanted to point something out to you guys. He said, for those of you who pay close attention to tiny details, you've probably caught in past seasons how the character, Creed, would get his co-worker's
我的意思是，我听到了外星人。我听到了。显然，克里德说他喜欢在只有凯文和梅雷迪思的会议室里管理，他说，在房间的这一边，斯坦利、菲利斯、吉姆、泰德、埃尔罗伊。在房间的另一边，帕姆、梅雷迪思、菲利斯、克里德本人。我错过了那个。天哪。然后，你知道，我们有他的牛棚会议，他有他的海报板写着“Bobotty”，他让每个人帮他制作这个首字母缩略词。凯文说B代表商业。克里德非常兴奋，现实生活中的克里德想向你们指出一点。他说，对于那些密切关注微小细节的人，你们可能在过去几季中注意到克里德这个角色是如何把同事的
names wrong. Mm-hmm. He said, well, this was a choice I made for my character, and I never shared it with anyone. I never told anyone. I never asked for permission. I would get the scripts and people's names would often be accurate, especially in the beginning, and I would purposely say them wrong while we were filming, and no one ever corrected me on it. So I just kept doing it. But this time, he said, because Creed was the branch manager, he thought, no, I'm going to get Kevin's name correct. Oh, what a great tidbit. I know. I thought that was so cute. Also, at 59 seconds during the scene, you can clearly see John starting to break. Jenna, he looks over at you, and he's about to lose it.
名字弄错的。嗯哼。他说，嗯，这是我为我的角色做出的选择，我从未与任何人分享过。我从未告诉过任何人。我从未请求过许可。我会拿到剧本，人们的名字通常是准确的，特别是在开始时，我会故意在拍摄时说错它们，没有人纠正过我。所以我只是继续这样做。但这一次，他说，因为克里德是分公司经理，他想，不，我要把凯文的名字说对。噢，多好的花絮。我知道。我觉得那太可爱了。此外，在场景的59秒时，你可以清楚地看到约翰开始破功。珍娜，他看着你，他快要忍不住了。
Oh, I know. We had a fan question from Brittany in Sunbury, Ontario, who said, how on earth did you get through those scenes with Creed as manager? How many takes did you have to do for those, and how many times did John Krasinski break? Brittany, every time he broke, every time. And I think what Angela is pointing out is you can see it like we had no footage of him not breaking or almost breaking. He is so clearly not, Jim, at 59 seconds. I know. He's just trying to turn away, I think, to avoid camera, but the camera caught him. Well, now we're going to have the opening credits. You guys remember, Michael would always take his Dundee and kind of put it into position on his desk, right? Well, now that he's gone,
噢，我知道。我们有一个来自安大略省萨德伯里的粉丝问题，他说，你们到底是怎么熬过那些克里德当经理的场景的？你们必须拍多少次，约翰·卡拉辛斯基破功了多少次？布列塔尼，每次他都破功，每次。我想安吉拉指出的是，你可以看到，就像我们没有他没破功或差点破功的镜头。他在59秒时显然不是吉姆。我知道。我想他只是试图转过身去，以避免镜头，但镜头拍到了他。好吧，现在我们要开始片头字幕了。你们记得，迈克尔总是会拿着他的邓迪奖杯，把它放在桌子上的位置，对吧？好吧，现在他走了，
each new boss has a little moment where they take a figurine and position it on their desk in the opening credits. A little recap for you. In Inner Circle, D'Angelo adjusts a Southwestern figurine. In Dwight K. Schrute, acting manager, Dwight adjusts a showgun statue. And in search committee, Creed adjusts a fan made in the shape of a sumo wrestler. I had to ask Creed about this. Oh. And here is what he said. He said, Ang, that little fan slash sumo wrestler statue was on my desk on the very first day of filming. It was on his original desk. Yes. Wow. He said it was with him for the entire run of the show. And he said it was one of the things he took when the office wrapped and he has it to this day. That is pretty cool. He said it's
每个新老板在片头字幕中都有一个小瞬间，他们拿着一个小雕像并把它放在桌子上。给你们一个小回顾。在《内圈》中，迪安杰洛调整了一个西南风格的小雕像。在《德怀特·K·舒鲁特，代理经理》中，德怀特调整了一个将军雕像。在《搜寻委员会》中，克里德调整了一个做成相扑选手形状的扇子。我不得不问克里德关于这个的事。噢。这是他说的。他说，安吉，那个小扇子/相扑选手雕像在拍摄的第一天就在我的桌子上。它在他原来的桌子上。是的。哇。他说它在整个剧集期间都和他在一起。他说这是《办公室》结束时他拿走的物品之一，他至今还留着它。那太酷了。他说它
really odd looking. But he was like, I have to have it. This is reminding me of my pen with the wonky broken giraffe on the end of it on like a little broken spring. Yeah. That was in my pencil cup. And I still have it in my pencil cup at home now. Yeah. Just some odd trinket. Some odd trinket. I have the cat paper clip holder that has the chipped ear. It's on my desk from day one. I wish that I had that weird like, you remember it? We talked about it a long time ago when we were breaking down our desks like back in season one. It was like a plastic colorful thing that had like spiky things coming out of it. Yeah. Different colors. Different colored plastic things on it. I mean, wow, could I be describing it worse? I don't think so. But I wish I had that
看起来真的很奇怪。但他当时想，我必须拥有它。这让我想起了我的笔，末端有一个歪歪扭扭的破长颈鹿，在一个小破弹簧上。是的。那在我的笔筒里。我现在在家里还把它放在笔筒里。是的。只是一些奇怪的小饰品。一些奇怪的小饰品。我有那个耳朵有缺口的猫形回形针架。它从第一天起就在我的桌子上。我希望我有那个奇怪的，像，你记得吗？我们很久以前在拆解我们的桌子时谈过它，就像在第一季。它就像一个塑料的彩色东西，上面有像尖刺一样的东西出来。是的。不同的颜色。上面有不同颜色的塑料东西。我的意思是，哇，我还能描述得更糟吗？我不这么认为。但我希望我有那个
thing. But it did eventually disappear. Like when Pam took it to Michael Scott paper company, it was in her box. But I don't think it ever returned. Well, at one minute and 25 seconds, Creed is playing the guitar in his office for some women. I was wondering if these women had a name if they were described at all. All I could find in the shooting draft is that Creed tells Jordan his friend Ace is stopping by. Hmm. Not sure this lady looks like an Ace. I asked Creed about this scene and he said, actually, there were two women. One is dancing, one is seated. They were both dressed kind of like hippies and that they just told Creed to play his guitar and that's his actual guitar. And he's actually playing. Nice. I guess Creed just has friends stop by.
东西。但它最终确实消失了。就像帕姆把它带到迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司时，它在她的盒子里。但我不认为它回来过。好吧，在1分25秒时，克里德在办公室里为一些女性弹吉他。我想知道这些女性是否有名字，如果她们有任何描述的话。我在拍摄草稿中唯一能找到的是克里德告诉乔丹他的朋友艾斯要过来。嗯。不确定这位女士看起来像艾斯。我问了克里德关于这个场景的事，他说，实际上，有两个女人。一个在跳舞，一个坐着。她们都穿得像嬉皮士，他们只是告诉克里德弹他的吉他，那是他真正的吉他。而且他真的在弹。不错。我想克里德只是有朋友过来。
Those two women, they were just background performers. That was a great day of work. I mean, you get to just sit in an office and listen to Creed play guitar. That's kind of awesome. Yeah. I love every time Creed played his guitar. Well, now we're going to go into the conference room and we're going to meet our first applicant. His name is Fred Henry. A man with two first names. Oh, good point. Fred Henry was played by Will Arnett. Will kind of talked a little bit about this scene. I love it that he has a three step plan to double their profits, but you know, he's only going to share the plan if he gets the job. And then they're like, well, how do we know you have a plan? And then he's like, I wouldn't tell you I have a plan
那两个女人，她们只是背景演员。那是很棒的一天工作。我的意思是，你只需要坐在办公室里听克里德弹吉他。那挺棒的。是的。我喜欢克里德每次弹吉他的时候。好吧，现在我们要进入会议室，我们要见我们的第一位申请者。他的名字叫弗雷德·亨利。一个有两个名字的男人。噢，好观点。弗雷德·亨利由威尔·阿奈特饰演。威尔谈了一点关于这个场景的事。我喜欢他有一个三步计划来翻倍他们的利润，但你知道，他只有在得到这份工作时才会分享这个计划。然后他们说，好吧，我们怎么知道你有计划？然后他说，如果我没有计划，我就不会告诉你我有计划
if I didn't have a plan. And then he shares just one one step of the plan, one part of one step, which is color code said documents to him. Yeah. I wanted to discuss. I think he's right to not share his plan to double their profits. Hmm. Why would he do that? I mean, I get it. They're like, but we need like, are you the real deal? Because then they could just take his idea. They don't need to hire him. Of course. Yeah. Yes. You know, this is a complaint of a lot of writers in Hollywood, which is that they'll get these meetings for a different show. And then part of your meeting is that you sit down and pitch ideas for this television show or this movie. But it's not, you don't own your ideas. Like once you give them in the interview, they can just like not hire you,
然后他只分享了计划的一步，一步的一部分，那就是对他进行颜色编码的文档。是的。我想讨论一下。我觉得他不分享翻倍利润的计划是对的。嗯。他为什么要那样做？我的意思是，我明白了。他们说，但我们需要，你是认真的吗？因为那样他们就可以直接拿走他的主意。他们不需要雇佣他。当然。是的。你知道，这是好莱坞许多编剧的抱怨，那就是他们会得到这些不同节目的会议。然后你会议的一部分就是你坐下来为这个电视节目或这部电影推销想法。但这不是，你不拥有你的想法。就像一旦你在面试中给出了它们，他们就可以像不雇佣你一样，
but they can be like, those are a couple of good ideas. Yeah. I mean, it makes sense to me. When is it your intellectual property and when is it not? Lady, I one time auditioned for a show. Yeah. And I improvised a line in my audition. Yeah. And I did not get the part and the line I improvised when I watched the show was in it. This is what I'm saying. I don't know. I think if they wanted the line, they need to hire you. I know. If they want your good idea, then you need to get the job. That's how I feel about it. You heard it from me. I'm with you. Jim's gonna have a talking head where he says, we are the search committee and the search committee is him and Toby and Gabe and they're looking for their candidates. And Jim did not know that Gabe's last name was Lewis.
但他们可以像，那些是几个好主意。是的。我的意思是，这对我来说很有意义。什么时候是你的知识产权，什么时候不是？女士，我曾经为一个节目试镜。是的。我在试镜中即兴发挥了一句台词。是的。我没有得到那个角色，当我观看节目时，我即兴发挥的那句台词在里面。这就是我所说的。我不知道。我觉得如果他们想要那句台词，他们需要雇佣你。我知道。如果他们想要你的好主意，那么你需要得到这份工作。这就是我的感受。你从我这里听到了。我和你在一起。吉姆会有一个谈话头，他说，我们是搜寻委员会，搜寻委员会是他、托比和盖博，他们正在寻找他们的候选人。吉姆不知道盖博的姓是刘易斯。
Hey, two first names again. Gabe Lewis. Oh, you know, my husband has two first names or two last names. That's true. Lee Kirk. Have we talked about this? Yes. And sometimes you go places and they're like Kirk Lee. Always. Always. 50% of the time. Hello, Mr. Lee. Now we're going to go to the elevator. Stanley, Darrell and Phyllis are all heading into work. They seem excited. They know Darrell is going to be interviewing today. And I think Darrell is kind of everybody's favorite choice for new manager. Yes. In the extended producers cut right after this elevator scene, there's a scene with Stanley and Phyllis and they're telling the camera operator that they're excited about Darrell being the new manager and they're rooting for him. And that didn't make it in
嘿，又是两个名字。盖博·刘易斯。噢，你知道，我丈夫有两个名字或两个姓。那是真的。李·柯克。我们谈过这个吗？是的。有时你去一些地方，他们会说柯克·李。总是。总是。50%的时间。你好，李先生。现在我们要去电梯。斯坦利、达里尔和菲利斯都在去上班的路上。他们看起来很兴奋。他们知道达里尔今天要面试。我觉得达里尔是每个人心目中新经理的首选。是的。在加长的制片人剪辑版中，就在这个电梯场景之后，有一个斯坦利和菲利斯的场景，他们告诉摄像师他们对达里尔成为新经理感到兴奋，他们支持他。那没有进入
the broadcast episode, but you kind of understand their energy from the elevator because they go right into this one-on-one with the camera that they're rooting for Darrell. Darrell is the most capable, most sober choice. Yes, he's the most level headed. Yes, absolutely. He's also shown himself to have great business ideas. He is who should be manager. Yeah. Now Craig Robinson did an interview though. Yeah. Around this time where he said, I don't want the job. Oh yeah. I like being just Darrell supporting character. I am not interested in leading conference room scenes and doing what Steve Carell did. So he was like, I don't want it. Like Craig Robinson was like, I don't want Darrell to be manager. Well, Andy really wants to be manager and he's going all
广播剧集，但你从电梯里能理解他们的能量，因为他们直接进入了这个与摄像机的一对一，他们支持达里尔。达里尔是最有能力、最清醒的选择。是的，他是最冷静的。是的，绝对。他还表现出自己有很好的商业想法。他应该是经理。是的。现在克雷格·罗宾逊做了一个采访。是的。大约在这个时候，他说，我不想要这份工作。噢，是的。我喜欢只做达里尔这个配角。我对领导会议室场景和做史蒂夫·卡瑞尔做过的事不感兴趣。所以他说，我不想要它。就像克雷格·罗宾逊说，我不想要达里尔当经理。好吧，安迪真的很想当经理，他全力以赴
out. He has a pin that says Andy for manager and he's putting up posters around the office with this catchy slogan. If you are on the search committee, please consider Andy. Is he running for school president or is he applying for a manager job? This is exactly what I thought. It made me think of this guy when I was in high school that ran for student council and he made posters. His name was Doug and he made posters that said plug for Doug. I know. He put them everywhere and I feel like this is kind of like Andy with his slogan and posters. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. What? Plug for, I can't even say it. I know. I know. Plug for Doug. I know. Jenna, I'll never forget it because we were like, what are you doing? This led me to Google American campaign
。他有一个写着“安迪当经理”的徽章，他在办公室周围贴上海报，上面有这个吸引人的口号。如果你在搜寻委员会，请考虑安迪。他是在竞选学校主席还是在申请经理工作？这正是我想的。这让我想起了我高中时的一个家伙，他竞选学生会，他制作了海报。他的名字叫道格，他制作了写着“支持道格”的海报。我知道。他把它们贴得到处都是，我觉得这有点像安迪和他的口号及海报。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。什么？支持，我甚至说不出来。我知道。我知道。支持道格。我知道。珍娜，我永远不会忘记它，因为我们当时说，你在做什么？这让我去谷歌搜索美国竞选
slogans over the years. Okay. Oh my goodness. What a ride. I cannot share all of them. There are way too many, but I'm going to give you a few and I made up my own categories. Oh great. The categories are old timer. Keep it simple. Fantastic and hey now. Oh boy. These are not in chronological order. They are in order of my categories. Okay. Here we go. From the old timer category, Abraham Lincoln election 1864. Don't change horses midstream. That was his campaign slogan? That was one of them. That's like a saying now. I know. He coined that saying or was it a saying and then he used it as a campaign slogan? We don't know. But what we do know is Franklin Roosevelt liked it so much. He used it again in 1944. Really? Okay. Here's another one from William McKinley election 1900.
口号多年来的情况。好吧。噢，天哪。多么疯狂。我不能分享所有这些。太多了，但我会给你们几个，我自己编了类别。噢，太棒了。类别是老派。保持简单。太棒了和嘿，现在。噢，男孩。这些不是按时间顺序排列的。它们是按我的类别顺序排列的。好吧。我们开始吧。从老派类别，亚伯拉罕·林肯1864年选举。不要在河流中间换马。那是他的竞选口号？那是其中之一。那现在就像一句谚语。我知道。他创造了那句谚语，还是它本来就是一句谚语，然后他把它用作竞选口号？我们不知道。但我们所知道的是富兰克林·罗斯福非常喜欢它。他在1944年又用了一次。真的吗？好吧。这是另一个来自威廉·麦金莱1900年选举的。
Let well enough alone. No. His campaign slogan was let well enough alone? Yep. What does that even mean? I don't know. This is why it's the old timer category. Now from the category, keep it simple. Okay. Dwight D. Eisenhower also known as Ike election 1952. I know this one. I like Ike. Exactly. Keep it simple. Next one and keep it simple. Dwight D. Eisenhower again in 1956. I still like Ike. Oh, there you go. And now from the fantastic category, Ulysses S. Grant 1872. Grant us another term. Wow. Mm-hmm. I was very torn within myself whether to label this category fantastic or. I see. Okay. Alfred M. Landon election 1936. Let's make it a Landon slide. And Thomas E. Dewey election of 1944. Dewey or don't we? No. No, that's not real. It is real.
让现状保持原样。不。他的竞选口号是让现状保持原样？是的。那到底是什么意思？我不知道。这就是为什么它是老派类别。现在从类别，保持简单。好吧。德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔，也被称为艾克，1952年选举。我知道这个。我喜欢艾克。没错。保持简单。下一个，保持简单。德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔在1956年又一次。我仍然喜欢艾克。噢，就是这样。现在从太棒了类别，尤利西斯·S·格兰特1872年。格兰特给我们另一个任期。哇。嗯哼。我内心非常纠结，不知道该把这个类别标记为太棒了还是。我明白了。好吧。阿尔弗雷德·M·兰登1936年选举。让我们来个兰登滑坡。还有托马斯·E·杜威1944年选举。杜威还是不杜威？不。不，那不是真的。它是真的。
Dewey or don't we? Dewey or don't we? Why are you even giving people the option to don't we? I know. In your campaign slogan. Well, lastly from the hey now category, Al Smith election 1928. Al Smith, someone named Al Smith ran for president? Yes, Jenna. In 1928, campaign slogan, make your wet dreams come true. No. What? This was referring to it. What? Wait, listen, this was referring to his stance in favor of getting rid of prohibition. He was referencing alcohol. He was gonna make all of this. Was he? Well, did we not have the term wet dream back in 1920, whatever? I don't think so. I don't think so. That campaign slogan did not age well. It did not. For him. Well, buckle in. Richard Nixon in 1972 had an official
Dewey or don't we? Dewey or don't we? 为什么你还要给人们“don't we”的选择？我知道。在你的竞选口号里。好吧，最后是“hey now”类别，1928年的阿尔·史密斯选举。阿尔·史密斯，有个叫阿尔·史密斯的人竞选总统？是的，珍娜。1928年，竞选口号是“让你的湿梦成真”。不。什么？这是指他的立场。什么？等等，听着，这是指他支持废除禁酒令的立场。他指的是酒精。他要让这一切……是吗？好吧，我们1920年左右还没有“湿梦”这个词吗？我不这么认为。我不这么认为。那个竞选口号没能经受住时间的考验。确实没有。对他来说。好吧，系好安全带。理查德·尼克松在1972年有一个官方
slogan that was keep it simple, Nixon now. Okay. But a few of his supporters and non-supporters had slogans in the hey now category. Okay. Here are two that really caught on with his supporters. They can't lick our dick. Wait, wait, wait. What? What is happening? I'm telling you. Next one. Don't change dicks in the midst of a screw. Vote for Nixon in 72. I don't understand what is happening. I know. These are slogans? These are slogans that caught on with his supporters. People had a lot of fun with his name. And now one from folks who did not support Nixon. I mean, I can't imagine his supporters ones are loony tunes. Okay. Dick Nixon before he dicks you. Now I like that one. Okay. I'm gonna have to say that's clever. Well, that's everything from hey
口号是“保持简单，现在就选尼克松”。好吧。但他的支持者和非支持者中也有一些属于“hey now”类别的口号。好吧。这里有两个在支持者中真正流行起来的口号。他们舔不到我们的老二。等等，等等，等等。什么？发生了什么事？我告诉你。下一个。别在做爱的时候换老二。72年投给尼克松。我不明白发生了什么。我知道。这些是口号？这些是在他支持者中流行起来的口号。人们拿他的名字开了很多玩笑。现在是一个不支持尼克松的人的口号。我的意思是，我无法想象他的支持者那些口号简直是疯了。好吧。“在尼克松搞你之前先搞尼克松”。现在我喜欢那个。好吧。我不得不说这很聪明。好吧，这就是“hey now”类别的全部内容了。
now. And that is my coverage of campaign slogans. That delighted me. I loved that. Thank you. Erin is very impressed by Andy's campaigning. And she really hopes that he gets it. And now we're gonna kick off a little storyline between Erin and Phyllis. We hinted at this in a previous episode, this idea that Erin might be Phyllis's long lost daughter that she gave up for adoption. And it seems like they both really want it to be true. Yeah, it's really sweet. We're basically going to find out that Erin was born in around the same time in region where Phyllis gave away a child. And the chances are slim, but they want to find it out. Yeah. And I guess they've done some sort of a test and they're waiting for these results. But in the meantime, Phyllis is
这就是我对竞选口号的报道。这让我很高兴。我喜欢这个。谢谢。艾琳对安迪的竞选印象非常深刻。她真的希望他能成功。现在我们要开启艾琳和菲利斯之间的一点故事情节。我们在上一集中暗示过这一点，这个想法是艾琳可能是菲利斯失散多年的女儿，她把她送去领养了。看起来他们俩都非常希望这是真的。是的，这真的很甜蜜。我们基本上会发现艾琳出生的时间和地点与菲利斯送走孩子的时间和地点大致相同。机会很渺茫，但他们想查清楚。是的。我想他们已经做了一些测试，正在等待结果。但与此同时，菲利斯
going to take on a very maternal role in Erin's life. And it's really quite sweet. Now we see Dwight at his desk. He is unshaven. It doesn't look like he's showered. He's eating a bag of chips and reading the newspaper. At four minutes 55 seconds, I want to know what is up with Raine's facial hair. Thank you for bringing it up because you said he's unshaven, but he's what? What? It's a patch. There's like a... But only on one side. Yeah, it's like a rectangle of hair that's slightly longer than the rest of the scruff. Slightly longer in a different color. It's very bizarre. I want to know what happened. It's very, very odd. I don't know if you noticed, but there is a computer game on Dwight's computer. This was, you know, to further
将在艾琳的生活中扮演一个非常慈母的角色。这真的很甜蜜。现在我们看到德怀特坐在他的办公桌前。他没刮胡子。看起来他没洗澡。他正在吃一袋薯片，读着报纸。在4分55秒时，我想知道雷恩的面部毛发是怎么回事。谢谢你提出来，因为你说他没刮胡子，但他是什么？什么？那是一块。就像有一个……但只在一边。是的，就像一块比其他胡茬稍微长一点的矩形毛发。颜色不同，稍微长一点。这非常怪异。我想知道发生了什么。这非常非常奇怪。我不知道你有没有注意到，德怀特的电脑上有一个电脑游戏。这是为了进一步
prove that he's not working. And that is unusual. You know, we're not going to see the character of Dwight ever playing games on his computer. He's all business. All business, but I liked that little detail that they made that point. He is not working. I did also notice next to the weird facial hair Pam's plant. Oh, yeah. It's a very nice plant. Oh, thank you. I didn't notice it. Now we're going to move into the conference room. We have another person interviewing for the job. He's very concerned about being reimbursed for his mileage and his long distance phone calls. This character was played by Warren Buffett. You guys know the billionaire Warren Buffett. Yeah. Yeah. A lot of questions about how this came about. And it's a very unique story.
证明他没有在工作。这很不寻常。你知道，我们永远不会看到德怀特这个角色在电脑上玩游戏。他一切以工作为重。一切以工作为重，但我喜欢他们指出这一点的小细节。他没有在工作。我还注意到奇怪的面部毛发旁边有帕姆的植物。哦，是的。那是一株非常漂亮的植物。哦，谢谢。我没注意到。现在我们要进入会议室了。我们有另一个人在面试这份工作。他非常关心他的里程费和长途电话费的报销问题。这个角色由沃伦·巴菲特扮演。你们认识亿万富翁沃伦·巴菲特吧。是的。是的。关于这是怎么发生的有很多问题。这是一个非常独特的故事。
Jonathan T. from Utica, New York actually wrote in and had some insider details. Oh. And I'm going to read you what he said. So he said, I have no idea if the cast remembers filming this, but here's the short film I saw featuring the cast of the office. He said, there's a conference room meeting and in walks, Warren Buffett, who announces that Dunder Mifflin has been bought out by Berkshire Hathaway and Warren Buffett is now the CEO of the company. I remember this. Yes. Everyone in the cast were sitting in the conference room. We react. Then Dwight stands up and says, I will be your number two, Mr. Buffett. And Mr. Buffett says, sorry, Dwight, but that position has been filled. In comes Charlie Munger who approaches Dwight and says Dwight,
来自纽约尤蒂卡（Utica）的乔纳森·T（Jonathan T.）实际上写信来提供了一些内幕细节。哦。我要读一下他说的内容。他说，我不知道演员们是否还记得拍摄这个片段，但我看到的短片里有《办公室》的演员。他说，有一个会议室会议，沃伦·巴菲特走了进来，宣布邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）已被伯克希尔·哈撒韦（Berkshire Hathaway）收购，沃伦·巴菲特现在是公司的首席执行官。我记得这个。是的。所有演员都坐在会议室里。我们做出反应。然后德怀特站起来说，我将成为你的二把手，巴菲特先生。巴菲特先生说，抱歉，德怀特，但那个职位已经有人了。查理·芒格（Charlie Munger）走了进来，走向德怀特说，德怀特，
right now there are 87. Wait. Then he adjusts Dwight's tie and says, 88 ways I could kill you right now. Jonathan says, mind you, these were not impersonators. It was the cast of the office and Rainn Wilson is Dwight. And he wants to know what are the details behind filming this little scene for the Berkshire Hathaway shareholder meeting? How did this come about? Did this happen during search committee? Well, Jonathan, we totally remember filming it. And it directly led to Warren Buffett's cameo on the show. So here's how it went down. Warren Buffett reached out to the producers of the office and asked if we would film something for his annual meeting. This is something we have never done before as a cast. This is not something that we would do.
现在有87种。等等。然后他整理了一下德怀特的领带说，有88种方法我现在可以杀了你。乔纳森说，请注意，这些不是模仿者。这是《办公室》的演员，雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）就是德怀特。他想知道为伯克希尔·哈撒韦股东大会拍摄这个小场景背后的细节是什么？这是怎么发生的？这发生在搜寻委员会期间吗？好吧，乔纳森，我们完全记得拍摄过程。它直接促成了沃伦·巴菲特在剧中的客串。事情是这样的。沃伦·巴菲特联系了《办公室》的制片人，询问我们是否愿意为他的年度会议拍摄一些东西。这是我们作为演员以前从未做过的事情。这不是我们会做的事情。
But Paul discussed it with us. And in exchange, we agreed as a cast that we would do it if Warren Buffett would make a donation to the Make-A-Wish Foundation. Make-A-Wish was a charity that we as a cast had supported over the years. We had a lot of people come through as part of their wish. It was one of our big charities that we worked with during the run of the show. Yes. Warren Buffett made a very, very generous donation to Make-A-Wish. And so we agreed to have him and Charlie Munger come to the set. And I guess while he was visiting, we were filming this episode and Greg Daniels said, hey, would you also do a cameo on the show? And Warren Buffett agreed. And that is how that all happened. It was just a sort of crazy bit of timing.
但保罗（Paul）和我们讨论了这件事。作为交换，我们作为演员同意，如果沃伦·巴菲特向“许愿基金会”（Make-A-Wish Foundation）捐款，我们就愿意这样做。“许愿基金会”是我们作为演员多年来一直支持的慈善机构。我们有很多孩子通过他们的愿望来到这里。这是我们在剧集播出期间合作的主要慈善机构之一。是的。沃伦·巴菲特向“许愿基金会”捐了一笔非常非常慷慨的款项。所以我们同意让他和查理·芒格来到片场。我想在他访问期间，我们正在拍摄这一集，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）说，嘿，你愿意也在剧中客串一下吗？沃伦·巴菲特同意了。这就是事情的经过。这只是一个疯狂的时间巧合。
However, do you remember the little thing that happened when Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger were there with the bathroom? Do you remember the bathroom thing that happened? No. You don't remember this? What? Okay. We don't know which one of them it was. Oh, I do. I do. One of them used the prop toilet. Yes. Oh my God. Yes. Yes. We don't know who it was. No one told them that the bathrooms in the kitchen are fake. Yes. They're all prop toilets. There's no running water. Yes. Oh my God. So one of them peed in the fake urinal. Mm-hmm. And it was like, there's no, it doesn't go anywhere. No, it's just like peeing in a bowl. Yes. Yes. At least it was pee. That's right. I mean, to be fair, they really look like real bathrooms. 100%. I can't believe it hasn't happened before,
然而，你还记得沃伦·巴菲特和查理·芒格在那里时发生的关于洗手间的小事吗？你记得发生的洗手间事件吗？不。你不记得这个了？什么？好吧。我们不知道他们中哪一个是这样的。哦，我知道。我知道。他们中的一个人用了道具马桶。是的。哦，天哪。是的。是的。我们不知道是谁。没人告诉他们厨房里的洗手间是假的。是的。它们都是道具马桶。没有自来水。是的。哦，天哪。所以他们中的一个人在假小便池里撒尿。嗯哼。就像，没有地方可以去。不，这就像在碗里撒尿。是的。是的。至少那是尿。没错。我的意思是，公平地说，它们看起来真的很像真正的洗手间。100%。我简直不敢相信以前没发生过，
frankly. I know. But after that, we put up signs. Yes, we did. That said, this is a fake bathroom. And they even like, remember, they would put tape over the toilet. Yes. And they only removed it when we were shooting. I totally forgot about that. Yeah. That was crazy. Angela, you're very happy in this next scene. I know. You know something's coming. I know. The senator has invited her to lunch at the Botanical Gardens. Scranton's hidden gym. She's very, very excited. Kevin warns her not to eat any berries that she doesn't recognize. Is Kevin eating berries at Botanical Gardens? Probably. Probably? Angela, I did something that I hope you will enjoy, which is a mini deep dive on the best Botanical Gardens in the world. Oh, I would love it. Let's hear it. Because this
坦白说。我知道。但在那之后，我们贴了标志。是的，我们贴了。上面写着，这是假洗手间。他们甚至，记得吗，他们会在马桶上贴胶带。是的。而且只有在我们拍摄时才会取下。我完全忘了那件事。是的。那太疯狂了。安吉拉，你在接下来的场景里非常开心。我知道。你知道有什么事要发生了。我知道。参议员邀请她去植物园吃午餐。斯克兰顿（Scranton）隐藏的瑰宝。她非常非常兴奋。凯文警告她不要吃任何她不认识的浆果。凯文在植物园吃浆果吗？可能吧。可能？安吉拉，我做了一件事，希望你会喜欢，那就是对世界上最好的植物园进行了一次小型深度游。哦，我很乐意。让我们听听。因为这
should be like bucket list for us. Mm-hmm. All right. The number one best Botanical Garden in the world on every list I looked at is Kew Gardens in England. Have you been there? No. I have not either. We have to go. It is a UNESCO World Heritage Site. There are more than 50,000 plants, including the world's largest water lilies. But you're going to like this, Angela. Oh, they have hydrangeas. Probably. Oh. They have a giant greenhouse that is separated into different zones. Each zone creates a unique climate so that they can host all kinds of different plants. And they have a whole section on succulents. Oh, yes. I think you would like it. I would like it. I love how many hydrangeas were in England. I would literally make the family
应该像我们的遗愿清单一样。嗯哼。好吧，我在每一个名单上看到的世界上排名第一的植物园是英国的邱园（Kew Gardens）。你去过那里吗？不。我也没去过。我们必须去。它是联合国教科文组织世界遗产。那里有超过50,000种植物，包括世界上最大的睡莲。但你会喜欢这个的，安吉拉。哦，他们有绣球花。可能吧。哦。他们有一个巨大的温室，被分成不同的区域。每个区域创造一个独特的气候，这样他们就可以容纳各种各样的植物。他们还有一个专门的多肉植物区。哦，是的。我想你会喜欢的。我会喜欢的。我喜欢英国有多少绣球花。我真的会让家人
like stop on our walks and I'd be like, I need a photo with these hydrangeas. Have you considered a coffee table book that is just photos of all the plants that you've taken pictures of on your walks and on your travels? No. Just for yourself. Maybe when I'm like an older lady, I'll do that. I'll just take pictures of flowers and hummingbirds and give it as a gift. That's what everyone wants. Give it as a gift to yourself. All right. Also noted on these lists were the Botanical Gardens in Singapore, Rio de Janeiro, Norway, and Cape Town, South Africa. In the United States, there were three gardens that were featured on the best of list. They are the New York Botanical Garden in the Bronx, which I've heard a lot about
在散步时停下来，我会说，我需要和这些绣球花合影。你有没有考虑过出一本咖啡桌书，里面全是你散步和旅行时拍的植物照片？不。只是为你自己。也许当我像个老太太的时候，我会那样做。我只会拍花和蜂鸟的照片，然后把它当作礼物送人。那是每个人都想要的。把它当作礼物送给自己。好吧。名单上还提到了新加坡、里约热内卢、挪威和南非开普敦的植物园。在美国，有三个植物园被列入最佳名单。它们是布朗克斯的纽约植物园，我听说过很多次
and haven't been to yet. It was modeled after Q Gardens, the Desert Botanical Garden in Phoenix, and I am very proud to say the Missouri Botanical Garden in St. Louis, Missouri. Hey, my parents go all the time. It has an 8,000 square foot butterfly house. It's absolutely gorgeous. Way to go, St. Louis. If I ever get to come home with you, I want to go there. Of course. Okay. Yes. They also have the corpse flower. Do you know about the corpse flower? It's a giant thing, right? It's very big and when it blooms, it only blooms for like 24 hours. Yes. And when it blooms, it smells like rotting flesh. Oh. My parents stood in line for it because it bloomed a few years ago in St. Louis.
但还没去过。它是仿照邱园建造的，凤凰城的沙漠植物园，我非常自豪地说，还有密苏里州圣路易斯的密苏里植物园。嘿，我父母经常去那里。它有一个8,000平方英尺的蝴蝶屋。它绝对华丽。干得好，圣路易斯。如果我以后能和你一起回家，我想去那里。当然。好的。是的。他们还有尸花（corpse flower）。你知道尸花吗？它是个巨大的东西，对吧？它非常大，当它开花时，它只开大约24小时。是的。当它开花时，闻起来像腐烂的肉。哦。我父母排队去看它，因为它几年前在圣路易斯开花了。
Did they witness the corpse flower? They saw it, but they said by the time they got in there, it had started to not smell anymore. So it blooms for 24 hours, but the smell is only like six to seven hours. Like, it doesn't smell the whole time. Yeah. So they missed the smell, but they saw the bloom. Well, maybe that's not the worst thing. I know. Oh, I agree. And so ends my mini deep dive on Botanical Gardens. I really want to go to the one in England. I mean, listen, I will go to all of them.
他们见证了尸花吗？他们看到了，但他们说当他们进去的时候，它已经开始不再有味道了。所以它开花24小时，但气味只有大约6到7小时。就像，它不会一直有味道。是的。所以他们错过了气味，但他们看到了花朵。好吧，也许那不是最糟糕的事情。我知道。哦，我同意。我的植物园小型深度游就到此结束了。我真的很想去英国的那个。我的意思是，听着，我会去所有的那些。
You will never, ever have to twist my arm to go on a road trip to see plants and flowers. I just feel like I should go on record saying that. So noted. Lady, should we take a break because when we come back, we're going to meet a fantastic candidate, Robert California, and I just, I need to marinate in it because I love to the scene so much. Talk about a lesson in scene study and how to command a room. James Spader is Robert California in this interview is not to be missed. Let's take a break and then we'll come back and talk about it. We are back and we are about to meet a former refinery equipment salesman named Robert California.
你永远永远不需要强迫我去公路旅行看植物和花。我觉得我应该记录在案。知道了。女士，我们要休息一下吗？因为回来后，我们将见到一位出色的候选人，罗伯特·加利福尼亚（Robert California），我只是，我需要沉浸在其中，因为我太喜欢这个场景了。谈谈场景研究和如何掌控房间的课程。詹姆斯·斯派德（James Spader）在这次面试中饰演罗伯特·加利福尼亚，不容错过。让我们休息一下，回来后再谈。我们回来了，我们即将见到一位名叫罗伯特·加利福尼亚的前炼油设备推销员。
Yes. Toby is going to ask like, how does your experience as like a refinery equipment salesman sort of translate into the world of paper? And Robert California has a speech that it needs to be heard. It does. Let's listen to it. I sit across from a man. I see his face. I see his eyes. Now, does it matter if he wants $100 of paper or $100 million of deep seed drilling equipment? Don't be a fool. He wants respect. He wants love. He wants to be younger. He wants to be attractive. There is no such thing as a product. Don't ever think there is. There is only sex. Everything is sex. Do you understand that what I'm telling you is a universal
是的。托比（Toby）会问，你作为炼油设备推销员的经验是如何转化为纸张世界的？罗伯特·加利福尼亚有一段演讲，需要被听到。确实。让我们听听。我坐在一个男人对面。我看着他的脸。我看着他的眼睛。现在，他想要100美元的纸还是1亿美元的深海钻探设备重要吗？别傻了。他想要尊重。他想要爱。他想要更年轻。他想要有吸引力。根本没有产品这回事。永远不要认为有。只有性。一切都是性。你明白我告诉你的是一个普遍的
truth, Toby? Yes. I mean, I hung on his every word. I mean, the scene continues and it's so rich. Yes. We had a fan question from Susanna H in Clermont, Florida who said, did they pick James Spader and then write Robert California for him to play or did they create Robert California and cast James Spader because he's perfect for it? I kind of mentioned this earlier. They created Robert California first and then Paul had the idea of James Spader to play this role. It is perfect. I loved it. I know for certain that James Spader memorized that word for word because later in season eight, when we go on to work with him, he was like a word for word actor. It's exactly as it's scripted. Yes. And he talked about someone who just has such a presence
真理吗，托比？是的。我的意思是，我听得入迷了。我的意思是，场景还在继续，而且非常丰富。是的。我们有一个来自佛罗里达州克莱蒙特（Clermont）的苏珊娜·H（Susanna H）的粉丝提问，她说，他们是先选了詹姆斯·斯派德，然后为他写了罗伯特·加利福尼亚这个角色，还是他们先创造了罗伯特·加利福尼亚，然后选了詹姆斯·斯派德，因为他非常适合这个角色？我之前提到过这一点。他们先创造了罗伯特·加利福尼亚，然后保罗有了让詹姆斯·斯派德扮演这个角色的想法。这太完美了。我喜欢它。我确定詹姆斯·斯派德逐字逐句地背下了那段话，因为在第八季后期，当我们继续和他合作时，他就像一个逐字逐句的演员。这和剧本完全一样。是的。他谈到了一个仅仅有那种存在感的人
and Paul and Zach and John's reactions as their characters to him are so great too. They are terrified of him. They're mesmerized by him and then his like look to camera at the end. Yeah. Paul said James immediately knew how to put a button to the camera and it was pretty amazing. Well, a great line for anyone in an interview. If anyone ever says to you, we think you might be overqualified, just look right at him and say, do I look like someone that would waste my own time? It's amazing. Well, his interview is done. Robert California is going to exit the conference room and he sizes up the whole bullpen and you can feel his gaze. It affects everybody.
保罗、扎克（Zach）和约翰（John）作为角色对他的反应也太棒了。他们被他吓坏了。他们被他迷住了，然后他在最后看向镜头。是的。保罗说詹姆斯立刻就知道如何给镜头一个结尾，这太神奇了。好吧，对于面试中的任何人来说，这都是一句很棒的话。如果有人对你说，我们认为你可能资历过高，只需直视他并说，我看起来像那种会浪费自己时间的人吗？这太棒了。好吧，他的面试结束了。罗伯特·加利福尼亚要离开会议室了，他打量了整个办公区，你可以感觉到他的目光。它影响了每个人。
Jim says that he creeps him out but he might just be a genius. Mm-hmm. And now it's time for Daryl's interview. But Daryl, I think he thinks he's just going to get the job. He has not prepared a resume. This is very un-Daryl. Like because in the warehouse, he's so prepared. But I think you're right. I think he thought he was a shoe in. Like this is a formality. Yeah. We got a lot of mail about this storyline with Daryl and kind of like you said about how you kind of can't believe. It seems out of character that Daryl wasn't more prepared. This was a criticism. All I could think of was maybe he's never had to do an interview. Like maybe at the warehouse,
吉姆（Jim）说他让他感到毛骨悚然，但他可能只是个天才。嗯哼。现在是达里尔（Daryl）面试的时间了。但达里尔，我想他认为他肯定会得到这份工作。他没有准备简历。这非常不像达里尔。因为在仓库里，他准备得非常充分。但我认为你是对的。我想他以为他稳操胜券。就像这只是个形式。是的。我们收到了很多关于达里尔这个故事情节的邮件，就像你说的，你简直不敢相信。达里尔没有做更充分的准备似乎不符合他的性格。这是一个批评。我能想到的唯一一件事就是也许他从来不需要面试。就像也许在仓库里，
he was hired and worked his way up or something. But it didn't track for me. It didn't track with a lot of fans and it also didn't track with Miles McNutt at the AV Club. Oh, Miles. This was one of his main criticisms of this episode, which he otherwise scored as a B minus. Okay. He said, quote, while I can understand Daryl expecting that he would get the job based on his strong relationships with people, the idea of not even bothering with a resume seems to reduce his intelligence too far. He can still have hubris without seeming entirely unprofessional. And I don't even think it was worth it for a clippy joke. He's not wrong, Miles. You're not wrong. You're not wrong.
他是被雇佣的，然后一步步升上来的之类的。但这对我来说说不通。很多粉丝也觉得说不通，AV俱乐部（AV Club）的迈尔斯·麦克纳特（Miles McNutt）也觉得说不通。哦，迈尔斯。这是他对这一集的主要批评之一，他给这一集打了B减。好吧。他说，引用一下，虽然我可以理解达里尔基于他与人们的牢固关系而期望得到这份工作，但连简历都不准备的想法似乎太贬低了他的智力。他可以在不显得完全不专业的情况下保持傲慢。而且我不认为这值得为了一个“回形针”（Clippy）的笑话。他没说错，迈尔斯。你没说错。你没说错。
I kind of agree. This felt a little too far out of character. We are now down in Caffeine Corner for one of my favorite scenes of the whole episode. Dwight is in the corner and he is watching an exchange between Merv Bronte and Robert California. Merv Bronte played by Ray Romano. He's coming in for his interview. As perfect as James Spader was for Robert California, I thought Ray Romano was perfection for Merv Bronte. Yeah. Merv just sort of says like, oh, you know, just how is it? He's making small talk. Yes. And Robert California, because he is just mischievous and somewhat sinister, plants the seed of doubt. He's like, you know, that just looks like a place where everyone is just working till they die. It's
我有点同意。这感觉有点太不符合性格了。我们现在在“咖啡角”（Caffeine Corner），这是我整集最喜欢的场景之一。德怀特在角落里，他正在观看默夫·布朗特（Merv Bronte）和罗伯特·加利福尼亚之间的交流。默夫·布朗特由雷·罗马诺（Ray Romano）饰演。他来面试。就像詹姆斯·斯派德是罗伯特·加利福尼亚的完美人选一样，我认为雷·罗马诺是默夫·布朗特的完美人选。是的。默夫只是说，哦，你知道，只是怎么样？他在闲聊。是的。而罗伯特·加利福尼亚，因为他只是淘气且有点阴险，种下了怀疑的种子。他说，你知道，那看起来就像一个每个人都在工作到死的地方。这
like dreadful up there. It's horrible. Yeah. And Merv gets in the elevator and Robert is in Merv's head. Merv gets in the elevator and he's like, no, I don't even know if I want his job. Yeah. Well, Dwight doesn't care for what Robert California has said about Dunder Mifflin. And he's like, what qualifies you to make these judgments? And Robert California just stares him down. And Dwight's like, stop it. Stop trying to figure me out. Already figured you out. Oh, it's already done. I mean, I loved the two of them going toe to toe here. How fun for rain. That must have been so fun as an actor. Yes. Yeah. I mean, I feel like also of all the applicants, we see Robert California interact with other office members. Yes. You know, mostly the applicants are just with
在上面太可怕了。太糟糕了。是的。默夫进了电梯，罗伯特就在默夫的脑子里。默夫进了电梯，他说，不，我甚至不知道我是否想要他的工作。是的。好吧，德怀特不喜欢罗伯特·加利福尼亚对邓德·米夫林的评价。他说，你有什么资格做出这些判断？罗伯特·加利福尼亚只是盯着他看。德怀特说，停下。别再试图看穿我了。已经看穿你了。哦，已经完成了。我的意思是，我喜欢他们两个在这里针锋相对。这对雷恩来说多有趣啊。作为一个演员，那一定很有趣。是的。我的意思是，我觉得在所有申请者中，我们看到罗伯特·加利福尼亚与其他办公室成员互动。是的。你知道，大多数申请者只是和
the search committee. But I have to imagine, I know that Paul said we had no plans to bring James Bader back for season eight. But I have to imagine that when they got in the editing room, and they saw this scene between Robert California and Dwight Shrew, I mean, I just as a writer, I would have begun having like a flurry of ideas. It's so great. How he affects everybody is so great. And of course, this is a plot point. We need to motivate Dwight to reapply. That's right. And now Dwight is like, I'm not going to let this guy get the job. And he's going to reapply. Merv, meanwhile, is going to have a sandwich during his interview. He has a line that made me laugh so hard. He says, they ask him why he left his other job. And he says, I'm leaving my other job because
搜寻委员会在一起。但我不得不想象，我知道保罗说我们没有计划让詹姆斯·斯派德回归第八季。但我不得不想象，当他们进入剪辑室，看到罗伯特·加利福尼亚和德怀特·施鲁特（Dwight Schrute）之间的这个场景时，我的意思是，作为一个编剧，我会开始有各种各样的想法。这太棒了。他影响每个人的方式太棒了。当然，这是一个情节要点。我们需要激励德怀特重新申请。没错。现在德怀特就像，我不会让这家伙得到这份工作。他要重新申请。与此同时，默夫在面试时要吃三明治。他有一句台词让我笑得很大声。他说，他们问他为什么离开上一份工作。他说，我离开上一份工作是因为
they were all jerks, really. Then he opens up his Tupperware and he starts eating a sandwich. And he says, you know, all of them, you had your jerk wads and your jerk offs. So just between the wads and the offs, I had to get out of there. I also noticed how Ray Romano, he didn't bite into his sandwich. He tore off a piece of sandwich. Do you bite your food or do you tear? Because it's a way to eat your sandwich. I mean, here's the thing. We don't really know Ray Romano. Maybe he normally eats a sandwich by just biting into it. But I love the character choice that this man, Merv, is like, all of a sudden annoyed, annoyed that he's there. So him like tearing at it, talking about the jerks and the jerk wads, it just fit for me for the story. But yeah,
他们都是混蛋，真的。然后他打开他的特百惠（Tupperware），开始吃三明治。他说，你知道，他们所有人，你有你的混蛋和你的混蛋。所以就在混蛋和混蛋之间，我必须离开那里。我还注意到雷·罗马诺是怎么做的，他没有咬他的三明治。他撕下了一块三明治。你是咬你的食物还是撕着吃？因为这是一种吃三明治的方法。我的意思是，事情是这样的。我们并不真正了解雷·罗马诺。也许他通常吃三明治就是直接咬。但我喜欢这个角色选择，这个男人，默夫，突然感到恼火，恼火他在这里。所以他撕着吃，谈论混蛋和混蛋，这对我来说很符合故事。但是的，
I generally bite into a sandwich. I think I'm going to put this in my acting journal that I keep of behaviors. You know, remember, I told you, one of mine is like, lady who applies lipstick immediately after finishing a meal. That's like a character trait. One of mine is nervous laughter lady. Yes. Yes, but she's like, how are you doing? Yes. And like then when I get a role, I go to my little journal and I see if any of these little quirks apply to my character. Well, I'm going to have to put down person who picks sandwich instead of bites into it. I bring sandwich to a meeting. Yeah. Yeah. Jenna, I was in a movie called Struck by Lightening and I was the high school counselor. The director was Brian Dannelly and we were talking about this
我通常会咬三明治。我想我要把它写进我保留的行为表演日记里。你知道，记得吗，我告诉过你，我其中一个习惯是，吃完饭后立刻涂口红的女士。那就像一个性格特征。我其中一个是紧张大笑的女士。是的。是的，但她就像，你怎么样？是的。然后当我得到一个角色时，我会去看我的小日记，看看这些小怪癖中是否有任何适用于我的角色的。好吧，我得写下，吃三明治而不是咬三明治的人。我带三明治去开会。是的。是的，珍娜，我拍过一部叫《闪电击中》（Struck by Lightning）的电影，我是高中辅导员。导演是布莱恩·丹内利（Brian Dannelly），我们正在谈论这个
scene. It's between my character and Chris Colfer, who's a high school student. Chris Colfer actually wrote the script and Chris and Brian and I were talking about like, what would my character be doing as students were coming in to talk to her and they were saying, well, maybe she took this meeting on her lunch break. She's eating a sandwich like through the whole scene. And I was like, oh yeah, that'd be great. And we decided on a big sloppy sandwich and it was so difficult to eat it and talk at the same time. Things were falling out of the sandwich. It was a hot mess. It made it into the bloopers. So Jenna, for your actor's journal, I'm just saying, be particular about the sandwich. Do I want a large sloppy sandwich?
场景。这是我的角色和克里斯·科尔弗（Chris Colfer）之间的，他是一名高中生。克里斯·科尔弗实际上写了剧本，克里斯、布莱恩和我正在谈论，当学生们进来和她交谈时，我的角色会做什么，他们说，嗯，也许她在午休时间开了这个会。她在整个场景中都在吃三明治。我说，哦，是的，那太棒了。我们决定吃一个又大又乱的三明治，一边吃一边说话太难了。东西从三明治里掉出来。那是一团糟。它进入了花絮。所以珍娜，为了你的演员日记，我只是说，对三明治要挑剔。我想要一个又大又乱的三明治吗？
Maybe I do. It sounds like it was a hit. Well, difficult to deal with in the moment, but provided some good comedy. I can put the bloopers in our stories and you tell me. Okay. It was the right choice. Well, we have Erin Sher to thank for that Ray Romano cameo. You remember that Erin was a writer on Everybody Loves Raymond. Yes. And Erin volunteered to reach out to Ray Romano and Ray said yes immediately. I loved, loved Ray Romano as Merv. Angela has returned to the office in a chauffeured car. Yes, you guys in the extended cut. Angela shows Hank her ring first before everyone else. Her giant ring. Yes. What is she Naomi Judd? I know. And Hank goes, damn girl. And I say, I know. And then she goes up to the office and
也许我想要。听起来它很受欢迎。好吧，当时处理起来很困难，但提供了一些很好的喜剧效果。我可以把花絮放在我们的故事里，你告诉我。好的。这是正确的选择。好吧，我们要感谢艾琳·谢尔（Erin Sher）促成了雷·罗马诺的客串。你记得艾琳是《人人都爱雷蒙德》（Everybody Loves Raymond）的编剧。是的。艾琳自愿联系雷·罗马诺，雷立刻答应了。我喜欢，喜欢雷·罗马诺饰演的默夫。安吉拉坐着专车回到了办公室。是的，你们在加长版里。安吉拉先给汉克（Hank）看了她的戒指，然后才给其他人看。她巨大的戒指。是的。她是娜奥米·贾德（Naomi Judd）吗？我知道。汉克说，该死，女孩。我说，我知道。然后她走到办公室，
shows it to the bullpen. So here's the thing about this ring. I remember Phil Shea coming over to me with a box of rings and they wanted it to be a showstopper. They wanted it to be a ring that Kelly would be impressed with. That's a good note. So it was about like three carrots with little diamonds on either side. I think it was a cushion cut or emerald cut. I can't remember. It was like one of those, right? Like the square rectangle. But it was really big. Jenna, I googled what rings that size cost and they are so expensive. Oh, yeah. I had no idea. Yeah. Your state senator, I don't know. He threw down some cash for that. Yeah. Something I didn't mention from the cliff hangers document and the seven pages of pitches that involved your character marrying the senator
给办公区的人看。关于这枚戒指，我记得菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）带着一盒戒指来到我身边，他们想让它成为一个引人注目的东西。他们想让它成为一枚凯利（Kelly）会印象深刻的戒指。这是一个很好的注意。所以它大约有三克拉，两边有小钻石。我想它是垫形切割或祖母绿切割。我不记得了。就像其中之一，对吧？就像方形矩形。但它真的很大。珍娜，我谷歌了一下那种尺寸的戒指要多少钱，它们太贵了。哦，是的。我不知道。是的。你的州参议员，我不知道。他为那个花了一些钱。是的。我没有提到悬念文档和七页涉及你角色嫁给参议员的推销中的一件事
is that in the end, there were several pitches where we were going to find out that the senator was corrupt. Oh. And you were going to have to deal with whether or not you turn him in. So he's getting money from somewhere. I mean, see, they planted the seed with this ring. How does he have this money? I don't know. Maybe it's a fake ring. Well, Angela starts to tell their engagement story. She says that he tucked a flower behind her ear and he got down on one knee to ask her to be a senator's wife and Pam laughs. And I'm saying right here and now that this is some Pam snark. She couldn't help herself. She said he talked about himself in third person. And Angela's like, yes, Pam, not everyone is as informal as you and Jim. Dude,
是最后，有几个推销是我们会发现参议员是腐败的。哦。你将不得不处理是否举报他。所以他从某个地方得到了钱。我的意思是，看，他们用这枚戒指种下了种子。他怎么会有这笔钱？我不知道。也许这是一枚假戒指。好吧，安吉拉开始讲述他们的订婚故事。她说他把一朵花别在她的耳后，他单膝跪地请求她成为参议员的妻子，帕姆笑了。我在这里说，这是帕姆的讽刺。她忍不住了。她说他用第三人称谈论自己。安吉拉说，是的，帕姆，不是每个人都像你和吉姆那样不拘小节。伙计，
would everyone marry me? And everybody laughs. Pam's like, that's not how it happened. And then one of my favorite things is Angela says, and then I saw flashes. Reporters were there. They always find us. And everyone was crying even as aid. Oscar is going to have a talking head where he says Angela is engaged to a gay man. And he says as a gay man and as Angela's friend, he's horrified, but as a lover of elegant weddings, he's excited. Yes. So Oscar has decided you're going to have a nice wedding. He's pretty sure. And he also finally can't hold on to this information anymore. He needs to let people know that Angela's engaged to a gay man. Guess who is going to interview for this job now? It's Andy. And listen, if you ever need anyone to give you a
每个人都会嫁给我吗？每个人都笑了。帕姆说，事情不是那样发生的。然后我最喜欢的事情之一是安吉拉说，然后我看到了闪光灯。记者们在那里。他们总是找到我们。每个人都在哭，甚至是助手。奥斯卡（Oscar）会有一个谈话头，他说安吉拉和一个同性恋男人订婚了。他说作为一个同性恋男人和安吉拉的朋友，他很震惊，但作为一个优雅婚礼的爱好者，他很兴奋。是的。所以奥斯卡已经决定你会有一个很棒的婚礼。他很确定。而且他终于无法再保守这个秘密了。他需要让人们知道安吉拉和一个同性恋男人订婚了。猜猜现在谁要面试这份工作？是安迪。听着，如果你需要任何人给你
pep talk, don't ask Phyllis because this is what she says. Are you sure this is a good idea? I hate to see you disappointed. Yeah. Well, right off the bat in his interview, Gabe is not having it. No, he's just sort of throwing out odd unrelated questions. How many windows are there in New York City? But then Andy throws down some serious knowledge about the sun, which causes Gabe to flip out and scream, shut up about the sun. Emma M in Florida wanted to know if that was scripted or improvised. Emma, that was scripted. Yeah, shut up about the sun. I feel like that would maybe make like a fun, ironic coffee mug. Shut up about the sun. Meanwhile, Darrell is working on his resume. And as Miles McNutt said, this is the clippy joke,
打气，不要问菲利斯，因为她是这么说的。你确定这是个好主意吗？我不想看到你失望。是的。好吧，在他的面试一开始，盖布（Gabe）就不买账。不，他只是抛出一些奇怪的无关问题。纽约市有多少扇窗户？但随后安迪抛出了一些关于太阳的严肃知识，导致盖布崩溃并尖叫，闭嘴，别再提太阳了。佛罗里达州的艾玛·M（Emma M）想知道那是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的。艾玛，那是剧本写的。是的，闭嘴，别再提太阳了。我觉得那可能会做一个有趣、讽刺的咖啡杯。闭嘴，别再提太阳了。与此同时，达里尔正在写他的简历。正如迈尔斯·麦克纳特所说，这就是“回形针”的笑话，
right? Yes. Remember clippy? This is old tech. It was part of Microsoft. Yes. When you would open a document, a little talking paper clip would come up. I remember clippy. I looked up clippy. Clippy's original name was Clipit. And Microsoft got rid of it years ago. Time labeled it one of the 50 worst inventions ever. Oh my gosh. There's a list of the 50 worst inventions? Yes. And Clippy is on it. But nearly three decades later, guess what? What? It's coming back. Clippy's coming back? Yes. According to the internet and also an article I read at SeattleMet.com, last year, Microsoft officially revived the office assistant that they debuted in Office 97. The character replaced a plain old paper clip in Microsoft 365 to help liven up the company's
对吧？是的。记得“回形针”吗？这是旧技术。它是微软的一部分。是的。当你打开一个文档时，一个小小的会说话的回形针就会出现。我记得“回形针”。我查了“回形针”。“回形针”的原名是Clipit。微软几年前取消了它。时代周刊将其列为有史以来50个最糟糕的发明之一。哦，天哪。有一个50个最糟糕发明的名单？是的。“回形针”就在上面。但近三十年后，你猜怎么着？什么？它要回来了。“回形针”要回来了？是的。根据互联网以及我在SeattleMet.com上读到的一篇文章，去年，微软正式复活了他们在Office 97中首次推出的办公室助手。这个角色取代了微软365中一个普通的老式回形针，以帮助活跃公司的
emojis and indulge a social media outpouring. Clippy can now permanently live in Word files, Outlook emails, or other common workplace apps. Well, listen, though coding circles treated Clippy like new Coke. Pop culture never quite quit the retired paper clip. When Daryl Philbin needed help with a resume in the season seven finale of the office, he pined for Clippy. Wow. And then it goes on to list all the different times Clippy came up in movies and TV shows. So one of the points this article is making is that while the coding circles thought Clippy was total crap, pop culture loved Clippy. Here was the thing. Clippy would come up, you're typing a document and Clippy would be like, are you sure you meant to say it that way? Yeah. And it would
表情符号并满足社交媒体的呼声。“回形针”现在可以永久地生活在Word文件、Outlook电子邮件或其他常见的办公应用程序中。好吧，听着，虽然编码圈把“回形针”当作新可乐（New Coke）。流行文化从未真正放弃这个退休的回形针。当达里尔·菲尔宾（Daryl Philbin）在《办公室》第七季大结局中需要简历帮助时，他渴望“回形针”。哇。然后它继续列出“回形针”在电影和电视节目中出现的所有不同时间。所以这篇文章提出的观点之一是，虽然编码圈认为“回形针”是彻头彻尾的垃圾，但流行文化喜欢“回形针”。事情是这样的。“回形针”会出现，你正在输入文档，“回形针”会说，你确定你是那个意思吗？是的。它会
give little suggestions or like if you needed help, you could ask Clippy, how do I change my margins Clippy? And then Clippy would tell you, but you could also just shut down Clippy from the beginning. Yeah, so it wouldn't talk to you. Yeah. Well, Clippy lived on in TV and movies and now is made to come back. I don't know how I feel about it. I know. Now we're going to get to a bit with Pam and Creed that gets quoted to me all the time and has been turned into a meme. And it is, they are the same picture. Oh, here's what's going to happen. Pam overhears Creed telling a long time client that Dunder Mithlin is going out of business. And she's like, oh no, this is on her. So she hands Creed two photos and says, you have to spot the seven differences between these photos.
给出一些小建议，或者如果你需要帮助，你可以问“回形针”，我怎么改变我的页边距，“回形针”？然后“回形针”会告诉你，但你也可以从一开始就关闭“回形针”。是的，所以它不会和你说话。是的。好吧，“回形针”在电视和电影中继续存在，现在又回来了。我不知道我对此感觉如何。我知道。现在我们要讲一个帕姆和克里德（Creed）的片段，这个片段经常被引用，并被做成了表情包。那就是，它们是同一张照片。哦，这是要发生的事情。帕姆无意中听到克里德告诉一位长期客户，邓德·米夫林要倒闭了。她说，哦不，这事关她。所以她递给克里德两张照片说，你必须找出这些照片之间的七个不同之处。
Corporate needs this. Yeah. It's very important. He doesn't ask, why does corporate need this? No questions. No. And then Pam simply has a talking head where she says, they're the same picture. Of all the things Pam says, I had no idea that was one that you get like quoted or said to you or used like on the internet. Oh, yeah. Like it's a whole thing. Like it gets used politically a lot. Like, you know, someone's trying to make some political point and they'll have like the meme of they're the same picture. Oh, I know. Well, one of the things I notice in this scene is how pregnant you are. Yeah. This is when you had bought your own shirts. Yep. It's true. Well, lady, because we spent a whole season pointing out my baby bump, I think whenever I
公司需要这个。是的。这非常重要。他没有问，为什么公司需要这个？没有问题。不。然后帕姆简单地有一个谈话头，她说，它们是同一张照片。在帕姆说的所有事情中，我不知道那是你被引用、对你说或在互联网上使用的一句。哦，是的。就像它是一回事。就像它在政治上被大量使用。就像，你知道，有人试图表达某种政治观点，他们会使用“它们是同一张照片”的表情包。哦，我知道。好吧，我在这个场景中注意到的一件事是你有多怀孕。是的。这是你买了自己的衬衫的时候。没错。好吧，女士，因为我们花了一整季的时间指出我的孕肚，我想每当我
see yours, I just get so tickled because it's your turn now. I know. And I still wasn't telling people. I know. It's so ridiculous. Well, I have two favorite lines in this episode. And one of them is going to be in Kelly's interview. Kelly says, well, I manage my department and I've been doing that for several years now. And God, I've learned a lot of life lessons along the way. And Jim says, your department's just you, right? And Kelly says, yes, Jim, but I am not easy to manage. That just makes me laugh. I think it's a great line. It really is. And she delivers it perfectly. Gabe is going to throw some Gabe sass and say, are we really taking her serious because we have a lot of other serious candidates? And Toby and Jim are like, no, no, no, we're going to give
看到你的，我就觉得很好笑，因为现在轮到你了。我知道。而且我还是没告诉别人。我知道。这太荒谬了。好吧，我在这一集里有两个最喜欢的台词。其中一个是在凯利的面试中。凯利说，嗯，我管理我的部门，我已经这样做了好几年了。天哪，我一路上学到了很多人生教训。吉姆说，你的部门只有你，对吧？凯利说，是的，吉姆，但我并不容易管理。这让我笑了。我认为这是一句很棒的台词。确实如此。她表达得非常完美。盖布要抛出一些盖布的傲慢，说，我们真的在认真对待她吗，因为我们还有很多其他认真的候选人？托比和吉姆说，不，不，不，我们要给她
her a full interview, Gabe. So Gabe says, okay, Kelly, what are your weaknesses? And Kelly says, I don't have any asshole. Yeah, that was a blur lip flap. Oh, I bet it was bleep or stage off camera. As previously mentioned, we got a fan question from Natalie G in Manhattan, New York, who said, I always wondered why Pam didn't apply for manager. She would have been a good manager. This also would have been a great story arc in which she can find confidence and seeing a female manager would have been great. Was this ever a consideration? Well, Natalie, there were a few story pitches about Pam applying to be manager. For example, one had her submitting a resume under a fake name just to see if she would even get an interview. We didn't end up doing that. But then
一个完整的面试，盖布。所以盖布说，好吧，凯利，你的弱点是什么？凯利说，我没有任何混蛋。是的，那是一个消音的唇部动作。哦，我敢打赌那是消音或在镜头外说的。如前所述，我们收到了来自纽约曼哈顿的娜塔莉·G（Natalie G）的粉丝提问，她说，我一直想知道为什么帕姆没有申请经理。她会是一个很好的经理。这也将是一个很好的故事弧，她可以在其中找到自信，看到一位女性经理会很棒。这曾经是一个考虑吗？好吧，娜塔莉，有一些关于帕姆申请经理的故事推销。例如，有一个让她用假名提交简历，只是为了看看她是否能得到面试。我们最终没有那样做。但随后
another had her actually getting to interview and kind of bombing. And then you had to see how Jim dealt with this reality, how they dealt with it as a couple that she just really didn't do great in her interview. And it was going to be a sweet moment, you know? Well, I'm glad they didn't do that because I don't need to see Pam fail at anything ever again. Yeah, it's been enough of Pam failing at her dreams. And her creating the office administrator position was such a win for her and was so empowering that that's that's the Pam I want to know. Also, honestly, I don't think Pam is qualified to be manager. She's only been in sales like a teeny weeny bit. And I know that Daryl has never really been in sales, but he managed a whole department. He's had a managerial
另一个让她真的去面试，结果搞砸了。然后你必须看看吉姆如何处理这个现实，他们作为一对夫妇如何处理她面试表现不佳的事实。那将是一个甜蜜的时刻，你知道吗？好吧，我很高兴他们没有那样做，因为我不需要再看到帕姆在任何事情上失败了。是的，帕姆在她的梦想上失败得够多了。她创造办公室管理员职位对她来说是一个巨大的胜利，而且非常赋权，这就是我想认识的帕姆。另外，老实说，我不认为帕姆有资格成为经理。她做销售只有一点点。我知道达里尔从来没有真正做过销售，但他管理过整个部门。他以前有过管理
position before. And there did end up being a sales element to that. Remember, like he came up with the commission for the people in the warehouse. Pam, however, she worked in sales for Michael Scott Paper Company. She worked in sales a little bit for Donor Mifflin. I'm not sure she's the person who should be managing a sales team, frankly. I don't know. So it's okay with me that Pam was not considered. I will say that. Well, right about now, Dwight is going to bust in to the conference room and say that he wants an interview. Yeah. And Jim's going to take him outside to the parking lot and just be like, Dwight, I mean, we we cannot have you as manager. Like, it's just not going to happen. And there's a great line as Dwight is trying to convince Jim
职位。而且最终确实有一个销售元素。记得吗，就像他为仓库里的人想出了佣金。然而，帕姆，她在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司（Michael Scott Paper Company）做过销售。她在邓德·米夫林做过一点销售。坦白说，我不确定她是否应该是管理销售团队的人。我不知道。所以帕姆没有被考虑对我来说没关系。我会说，好吧，就在这时，德怀特要闯进会议室说他想要面试。是的。吉姆要带他去外面的停车场，只是说，德怀特，我的意思是，我们不能让你当经理。就像，这根本不会发生。当德怀特试图说服吉姆时，有一句很棒的台词
where he says, quote, the hand that reaches from the grave to grip your throat is the strong hand you want on the wheel. That's going to come back in part two. It is. Did anyone notice when Jim and Dwight were walking through the parking lot talking, how many flippin zigzaggy power lines are on the street? No, I couldn't take my eye off them. Now, listen, I watched the episode like three times. The first two times I watched Jim and Dwight. Okay. Okay. But by the third watch, I was like, what's up with all these power lines? Well, to be fair, the third watch is for background catches. It is. We call it our background pass. I took a picture. I will put it in stories. I mean, it is craziness. It's
他说，引用一下，从坟墓里伸出来扼住你喉咙的手，就是你想要握住方向盘的那只强有力的手。这在第二部分会再次出现。确实。有人注意到吉姆和德怀特走过停车场聊天时，街上有多少该死的之字形电线吗？不，我无法把目光从它们身上移开。听着，我看了这集大概三遍。前两次我都在看吉姆和德怀特。好吧。好吧。但到了第三遍，我就想，这些电线是怎么回事？嗯，公平地说，第三遍是为了捕捉背景细节。确实。我们称之为背景检查。我拍了一张照片。我会把它发到故事里。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。它是
craziness. Oh, yeah. It's quite a few power lines. There's a lot. Yeah. All right. We were surrounded by electricity. Definitely. This next scene, I'm titling hot goss in the break room. Oh, it is hot goss. Oscar decides to finally spill the beans and he's going to tell Pam that he thinks Robert is gay. Pam pushes back and says, no, no, no, wait, he's married and has a kid. Oh my God, someone finally brings up Robert's kid. This never happens. Yes. And Pam says, wait a second, did you see Robert at a bathhouse? And Oscar's like, what? And she's like, yeah, the windowless building by the Baskin Robbins. Never mind. I'm never going to know what goes on in there. Lady, lady, listen to me. There is a windowless building that went in down the street
疯狂。哦，是的。电线确实不少。有很多。是的。好了。我们被电力包围了。绝对是。接下来的这一幕，我称之为休息室里的热门八卦。哦，这确实是热门八卦。奥斯卡决定终于说出真相，他要告诉帕姆他认为罗伯特是同性恋。帕姆反驳说，不，不，不，等等，他结婚了，还有个孩子。天哪，终于有人提起罗伯特的那个孩子了。这从来没发生过。是的。帕姆说，等一下，你在澡堂见过罗伯特吗？奥斯卡说，什么？她说，是的，就在巴斯金-罗宾斯旁边的那个没有窗户的建筑。算了。我永远不会知道里面发生了什么。女士，女士，听我说。我家街下确实有一栋没有窗户的建筑
from my house. They started building it. Me and my kids are obsessed with it. It has no windows. It has no sign. It has no business name on it. We watched it be built. We were like, this is so weird. Why would you make a windowless building? It's not a storage facility. It has an address on the side of the building. You can't see it from street. We have driven around it. We go by it. We keep waiting for them to put a sign on it. It's in business now. Windowless building in business. What do they do? I need so badly to walk into it. Well, you know, but I'm scared. Well, you know what I'm going to say. What? This is a case for mom detectives. This is a case for mom detectives. Angela, will you
他们开始建造它。我和我的孩子们对它着迷。它没有窗户。没有招牌。没有商业名称。我们看着它被建成。我们当时想，这太奇怪了。为什么要造一栋没有窗户的建筑？它不是仓储设施。建筑侧面有一个地址。从街上看不见。我们绕着它开过车。我们经过它。我们一直等着他们挂上招牌。它现在在营业。没有窗户的建筑在营业。他们是做什么的？我太想走进去看看了。嗯，你知道，但我很害怕。嗯，你知道我要说什么。什么？这是一个妈妈侦探的案子。这是一个妈妈侦探的案子。安吉拉，你愿意
put on a silly costume and disguise yourself and walk into the windowless building by my house? With you? Well, I'll be in the car. You're sitting there alone? I, since I live in the neighborhood, I'm afraid like what if it needs to, you know what I'm saying? It can't be anyone local. All right, I'll do it. Okay. I'll do it. But I felt this when Pam was like, I need to know what the windowless building by the Baskin Robbins. I was like, oh my gosh, I have this mystery in my own life. I will 100% go up there. You need to film me from the car, though. Of course. I will not. You need to have a little like fakey flower that is also a camera. Now, now, listen, what? I'm not going to go and buy one of those. This is like, what can we do
穿上一套滑稽的服装，伪装自己，走进我家旁边那栋没有窗户的建筑吗？和你一起？嗯，我会待在车里。你一个人坐在那儿？我，因为我住在附近，我担心如果它需要，你知道我在说什么吗？不能是当地人。好吧，我来做。好的。我来做。但当帕姆说，我需要知道巴斯金-罗宾斯旁边那栋没有窗户的建筑是什么时，我有同感。我就想，天哪，我自己的生活中也有这个谜团。我百分之百会去那里。不过你需要从车里拍我。当然。我不会的。你需要有一个像假花一样的摄像头。现在，现在，听着，什么？我不会去买那种东西的。这就像，我们能做什么
on a shoestring budget? That's true. Things from our home. Okay. But in season two, I think the moms are going to invest in fakey flower cameras. Fine. For their lapel. I was going to do this in real life. I wasn't even doing this as a TV show. No, I know. I'm just saying that as we use these real experiences to influence our television show. The TV shows. Yes. Yeah. Eventually, I just put a pin on that idea. Okay. Okay. I'll do it. I'll go knock on the door. I'm dying to know what it is. Oh, I know. I have the plan. What is it? I have the plan. What is it? Okay. Near my house is one of those like fruit basket companies. Okay. You know where you can get like the strawberries that look like little tuxedos, but they're in a basket or it's like
在预算有限的情况下？那是真的。用我们家里的东西。好的。但在第二季，我想妈妈们会投资购买假花摄像头。好吧。为了她们的翻领。我本来想在现实生活中做这件事。我甚至不是把它当作电视节目来做。不，我知道。我只是说，当我们利用这些真实的经历来影响我们的电视节目时。电视节目。是的。是的。最终，我只是把这个想法搁置了。好的。好的。我来做。我会去敲门。我太想知道那是什么了。哦，我知道。我有计划。是什么？我有计划。是什么？好的。我家附近有一家那种水果篮公司。好的。你知道你可以买到那种看起来像小燕尾服的草莓，但它们装在篮子里，或者像
pineapple on a stick, but half of it has chocolate. You know what I'm saying? I do. Okay. I'm going to get one of those. Okay. And I'm going to go to your windowless building. Yes. And I'm going to say I have a delivery for you. It's a fruit basket. Yeah. That's my plan. And then what if like you can't tell what it is from the lobby? Are you just going to be like a chatty delivery person that's like, Oh, what do you guys do here? Yeah. What's your business? Yeah. Or I could come and be disgruntled neighbor and say, Hey, we've had some noise complaints. I like the fruit idea. I feel like it's more me. Well, it's more you. It's going to be easier role for you to play. And then also I just think the hospitality of it is going to open them up. You know what I mean?
棍子上的菠萝，但一半裹着巧克力。你知道我在说什么吗？我知道。好的。我要去买一个。好的。然后我要去你那栋没有窗户的建筑。是的。我要说我有一个送给你们的快递。是一个水果篮。是的。那是我的计划。然后如果从大厅看不出那是什么怎么办？你只是要像一个健谈的快递员那样说，哦，你们在这里做什么？是的。你们的业务是什么？是的。或者我可以去扮演一个不满的邻居，说，嘿，我们收到了一些噪音投诉。我喜欢水果的主意。我觉得这更像我。嗯，这更像你。这对你来说是一个更容易扮演的角色。而且我也觉得它的热情好客会让他们敞开心扉。你知道我的意思吗？
It's going to be. Yeah. Yeah. Who's the fruit from? If they ask the city. Thank you for doing business here. Maybe a good time for me to tell you, I'm really bad at lying. I know. But I think you're very good at acting. So this is a role. This is not a lie. Right. This is a character that we're bringing onto the street. Yes. Think of it as performance art. It's performance art. I did a lot of that back in my improv days. We'll get back to you everyone on the windowless building by my house. I'm excited. Well, we're about to have some interviews with people from the UK. First up is David Brent. It's over video. He basically says if they're looking for a leader, he's ready. When does he start? So Paul E. Burstein reached out to Ricky Dervais about doing
它会是。是的。是的。水果是谁送的？如果他们问，城市。感谢你们在这里开展业务。也许现在是我告诉你的时候了，我真的很不擅长撒谎。我知道。但我认为你非常擅长表演。所以这是一个角色。这不是谎言。对。这是我们带到街上的一个角色。是的。把它看作行为艺术。这是行为艺术。我在即兴表演的日子里做过很多这种事。我们会回到大家关于我家旁边那栋没有窗户的建筑的话题。我很兴奋。好吧，我们即将对来自英国的人进行一些采访。首先是戴维·布伦特。是通过视频。他基本上说如果他们在寻找领导者，他准备好了。他什么时候开始？所以保罗·E·伯斯坦联系了瑞奇·热维斯，询问是否可以
an in-person cameo as one of the applicants. And Ricky really wanted to do it, but he was like working on another project at the time and he couldn't travel to LA. So first he pitched the idea of filming something in the UK. Like this was very elaborate. It was so nice of him though. He was like, I'll build like your lobby area and then I'll film my side of it. And maybe he's the last applicant and Pam's kind of like shutting down the office for the day and he walks in and then it would cut to me in the United States just sort of saying like, sorry, the interviews are over. And then he could also then have like a talking head. Or he said, I could just film like a video interview and you could use that. And Paul was like, I think that'll work better.
作为申请人之一进行现场客串。瑞奇真的很想做，但他当时正在做另一个项目，无法前往洛杉矶。所以他首先提出了在英国拍摄的想法。这非常复杂。不过他真是太好了。他说，我会搭建你们的大厅区域，然后我会拍摄我这一侧。也许他是最后一个申请人，帕姆正准备关掉办公室，他走了进来，然后画面会切到在美国的我，说，抱歉，面试结束了。然后他也可以有一个谈话头。或者他说，我可以只拍摄一个视频采访，你们可以使用那个。保罗说，我觉得那样效果更好。
I think, you know, that was to build the lobby and then get all the lighting right and everything. What if it didn't cut together right? Right, right. That could be like a little tricky. So Ricky sent in four options of interviews. We picked this one. I bet he did that so fast because that character is just so easy for him. Yeah. I mean, I could watch him do 70 interviews as that character. The next person from the UK to interview is going to be Nelly Bertram. Yes. Catherine Tate plays Nelly Bertram. My gosh, she is amazing. Such a funny comedian, had her own show in the UK, which is so funny. She's hilarious. She's another person I could just watch. Read the phone book. I love that I keep referencing a phone book that no one has
我想，你知道，那是为了搭建大厅并把灯光调整好等等。如果剪辑在一起效果不好怎么办？对，对。那可能会有点棘手。所以瑞奇发来了四个采访选项。我们选了这个。我敢打赌他做得很快，因为那个角色对他来说太容易了。是的。我的意思是，我可以看他以那个角色进行70次面试。下一个来自英国的面试者将是内莉·伯特拉姆。是的。凯瑟琳·塔特饰演内莉·伯特拉姆。天哪，她太棒了。真是个有趣的喜剧演员，在英国有自己的节目，非常有趣。她太搞笑了。她是另一个我可以一直看的人。读电话簿。我喜欢我一直提到的那个没人有的电话簿
but Catherine is so talented. You know, in the shooting draft, they had a different version of the scene that as I read it, I could hear her voice. It was so funny. And then this scene is hilarious to me. She just keeps waffling. She's like, first, she's like, no cubicles. And then they're like, hmm, and she's like, definitely cubicles. And then she's like, no, no, no, no cubicles. Everyone just sits on the floor. Everybody is their own boss. No, everybody's somebody's boss and she's going back and forth. So I guess Catherine Tate said yes immediately, like everyone else, but she was in rehearsals for a play when this was shooting. And she came to do our episode. She was in the United States for like 36 hours. Oh my gosh. She flew in,
但凯瑟琳太有才华了。你知道，在拍摄草稿中，他们有另一个版本的场景，当我读到它时，我能听到她的声音。太有趣了。然后这一幕对我来说太搞笑了。她一直在犹豫不决。她说，首先，她说，不要隔间。然后他们说，嗯，她说，一定要隔间。然后她说，不，不，不，不要隔间。每个人都坐在地板上。每个人都是自己的老板。不，每个人都是某人的老板，她一直在变来变去。所以我猜凯瑟琳·塔特像其他人一样立即答应了，但她在拍摄时正在排练一部戏。她来参加我们的剧集。她在美利坚合众国待了大约36个小时。天哪。她飞过来，
kind of came directly to set. And then I think she left the very next day because she had to get back for rehearsals. Is that crazy? That is just boss lady. I wanted to read you guys one little thing that was in the shooting draft about the very end of her interview. It didn't air, but I thought it was very funny. She says to Toby, well, what are you offering? And Toby says, well, and before he can finish, she says, right, I'll take it. Need a job desperate. Good match, sloppy match, whatever. Good match, sloppy match, whatever. That's pretty great. All right, final scene of this episode. Things are going to get real for Jim Halpert. Oh yeah. He's just going to grab a cup of coffee in the kitchen and Oscar says, is there a front runner? And he sort of casually
直接来到片场。然后我想她第二天就离开了，因为她必须回去排练。这不疯狂吗？那真是老板风范。我想给你们读一点拍摄草稿中关于她面试最后的一小段内容。它没有播出，但我认为非常有趣。她对托比说，那么，你提供什么？托比说，嗯，在他还没说完之前，她说，好吧，我接受。需要工作，绝望。好匹配，烂匹配，随便吧。好匹配，烂匹配，随便吧。那真是太棒了。好了，这一集的最后一幕。吉姆·哈珀特要来真的了。哦，是的。他只是去厨房拿杯咖啡，奥斯卡说，有领跑者吗？他随口
says, well, they're just all sort of blending together after a while. Maybe I'll just pick a name out of the hat. Oh, that doesn't go over well. Some Stanley sass is about to happen. He says, the hell you will. I worked for the last boss for 15 years. According to my doctor, I don't have another 15 years. If I want to keep up the same dietary and sexual lifestyle, which I intend to. Yes. My next boss will be my last boss. He'll be at my funeral. Yeah. Meredith is ticked off too. She's like, you pick a crappy boss, you're responsible for my crappy life. And then Oscar, Oscar's annoyed. Yeah. And then Ryan says, maybe, maybe Jim should take a day off from his Jim shtick and try caring about something for a change. Yeah. That was my second favorite
说，嗯，过了一会儿它们都混在一起了。也许我只是从帽子里抽个名字。哦，那可不太好。斯坦利的讽刺要发生了。他说，你敢。我为上一任老板工作了15年。根据我的医生的说法，我没有另外15年了。如果我想保持同样的饮食和性生活方式，而我打算这样做。是的。我的下一任老板将是我的最后一任老板。他会出现在我的葬礼上。是的。梅雷迪思也很生气。她说，你选个烂老板，你就得为我烂透的生活负责。然后奥斯卡，奥斯卡很恼火。是的。然后瑞安说，也许，也许吉姆应该从他的吉姆把戏中休息一天，试着关心一下某件事。是的。那是我的第二最爱
line in the whole episode. Little advice, take a day off from the whole Jim shtick. Yeah. And then he calls him James. And then he shuts his door to his little closet. Oh, well, that is a search committee part one. A big thank you to Will Arnett for sending in those audio clips and to Paul Lieberstein who traded countless texts with me so that I could get all my info right. And to Creed Bratton for chatting with me on the phone about being the branch manager. And finally, Randy Cordray. Guys, these were Randy's last episodes. So we're going to be saying goodbye to Randy after next week. And I don't want to stop emailing him every week. I just love it. I know Randy is the most lovely person. Not only has he been so gracious with his time and sending
整集里的台词。小建议，从整个吉姆把戏中休息一天。是的。然后他叫他詹姆斯。然后他关上了他小壁橱的门。哦，好吧，这就是搜索委员会第一部分。非常感谢威尔·阿内特发送那些音频片段，感谢保罗·利伯斯坦与我交换了无数条短信，以便我能准确获取所有信息。感谢克里德·布拉顿在电话里和我聊天关于担任分公司经理的事。最后，兰迪·科德雷。伙计们，这些是兰迪的最后几集。所以下周之后我们要和兰迪说再见了。我不想停止每周给他发邮件。我只是喜欢它。我知道兰迪是最可爱的人。他不仅在时间上非常慷慨，发送
us really detailed emails about each episode, but he's just a wonderful human. And he gives us emails of encouragement. He lets us know that we're doing it right. He checks in on us. We just adore him so much. Well, and that's how he was when he was the line producer of our show. Same person. All right. Next week, search committee part two. See you then. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
给我们关于每一集的非常详细的电子邮件，但他只是一个很棒的人。他给我们发鼓励的邮件。他让我们知道我们做得对。他会查看我们的情况。我们非常崇拜他。嗯，他在担任我们节目的制片人时就是这样。同一个人。好了。下周，搜索委员会第二部分。到时候见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。